- Vlog, late night, just
jamming and some stuff.
But it's interesting that,
just show the wine scene real quick, Iris.
There you go, you can
come right back to this.
2018, looking to do this format
much more often on my podcast,
get three to four
interesting friends together,
drink some wine, talk some shit.
This is a throwback to the first episode
in case you missed it.
I hope you enjoy it.
The first episode of Brown Paper Bag 2018.
Huge year for brown paper bags.
(smooth synthetic music)
Hey everybody, this is Gary Vaynerchuk
and this is a new...
I'm definitely gonna
do this more than once,
but maybe it will only be
a two thing thing ever,
but I doubt it.
I think this could become a new standard.
As many of you know who are listening,
I grew up in the wine world,
and I've been trying to figure out
ways to spend more time in it.
I miss it in a lot of ways
with all the stuff I've been doing in tech
and entrepreneurship.
And so, as my podcast continues to evolve,
in December we rebranded it
to the GaryVee Audio Experience,
which allowed me to do a lot
more things with it, obviously.
There's keynotes, there's original content
that I'm making for it, some rants.
But this one is completely
straight to podcast.
It's something I'm calling Brown Bags.
So this is episode one of Brown Bags
within the GaryVee Audio Experience.
And this comes from the favorite thing
that ever happened while
I was in the wine world
for the first kind of 20
years of my professional life,
which is, when you really
get nerdy about wine,
you start getting to a place where
you're trying to figure
out how good you are at it.
And one of the ways to do
that is to taste wines blind,
meaning, there's blind
where you kind of knew what the wines were
and you put 'em in a brown paper bag,
or tin foil, which we have here, set up,
and then you try to guess
them or analyze them,
or there's double blind,
which is my favorite,
which is, you literally don't
know what the wines are,
and they're in brown
paper bags, or tin foil.
And so, I've invited three
of my friends to join me,
and that's gonna be the format.
Between three or four people,
each episode, different
buddies from around the world,
from different walks of life,
and I'll introduce these beautiful
and wonderful people in two seconds.
And we will literally do the following,
the format of this show is,
we're gonna taste the wines,
we're gonna try to tell
ourselves whether we like it.
Once in a while we'll bring
in a real professional
like Andre here, who I'll
introduce in a minute.
Maybe we'll even get a little bit deeper
and really challenge ourselves,
and probably get exposed
or sometimes show amazing skills.
And then kind of talk
also about current events,
things in the business world,
or just the relationship I have
with these wonderful individuals.
So, before anything else,
I would love to get your
feedback on this format
so be very aggressive on
Twitter with the feedback.
Put feedback brown bags,
#feedbackbrownbags.
I'll search it.
That way, I'd love to
see what you guys think.
And so, let's do this,
let's start introducing.
Why don't we start with you, Mary Kate?
- Hi everyone, I'm Mary Kate McGrath.
I'm the Editor in Chief of PureWow,
which is a digital media company.
We write about all things
for women's lifestyle
including wine, so I'm very excited
that Gary just handed me a very heavy pour
of something white.
- Yes, that's true.
I'm pouring white wine right now.
- Very heavy-handed.
Can we even say that it's before lunch?
- Yeah, you can tell them what time it is.
- It's 10 in the morning, so,
this is actually my second glass today.
- But Andre, you've drank
much of wine, right?
- Yeah, a lot.
- Before 10 a.m.
Like a big percentage of the wine
that you've consumed in
your life, prior to 10 a.m.
- Absolutely, and it's probably--
- And especially if you
add in the fact that
once it's 12:01, it's the next day,
the majority of the wine
that you would consume--
- That's right, I would
say about 60 or 70 percent
of the wine, yeah.
- Yeah, we'll get to you
in a minute.
- Absolutely.
- Mary Kate, you also did not mention
that I bought PureWow in January
and now I am your ultimate
boss, and not Ryan Harwood,
who is not here.
- It's actually Gary's PureWow
- Should we rename it to GaryWow.com?
- Yes.
- Let's talk about that
after this podcast.
- Yes, I love it, I love it.
Yeah, it's done, I just did it.
- Good, Erin?
- Hi, I'm Erin Heatherton, and
you may know me from my
work with Victoria's Secret
and Sports Illustrated and,
maybe in the future for, you know,
getting drunk on this show this morning.
(laughing)
- And so Erin, tell everybody,
I know a lot of people who are listening,
like me, or sports fans.
I'm fascinated by your
true love of sports.
Give a little bit of like the content
or some of the stuff you've been doing
in that world 'cause
I'm intrigued by that.
- Yeah, so I was, I mean,
my parents are married because of sports.
That's all they do.
So, yes,
sports just played a huge role in my life.
I played basketball everyday.
I ran track, and, you know,
those experiences shaped who I am,
and they were the most kind of rewarding
and built my confidence,
in the kind of like,
I think everything I bring to the table
in the modeling world came from
being a competitive athlete
and having that mobility and kind of just,
being a model is a lot
like being an athlete
'cause you gotta perform with your body.
You gotta play good or you're not playing.
Yeah, that shaped me, and
also, I kind of figured,
at a certain point, for five
years I did high fashion,
so I did five years of fashion weeks,
so, it's like 10 fashion
weeks, it's a lot.
And I've been around all these,
you know I was plucked
kind of out of Chicago
and into New York, into this fashion world
that I wasn't involved in growing up,
and I got to a certain
point where I'm like,
you know, there nothing wrong,
I don't dislike anyone in fashion, but,
being at a party with a bunch
of people that love fashion,
I'm not really that,
I realized I'm just not that into fashion.
I would rather spend my
time being around people
who enjoy sports because
I understand those people.
Those people are, those are my people.
And so I kind of took, I realized that,
I'm like, I'm gonna take myself
from this corner of, I always
thought of it like kind of,
there's four frozen yogurt
stands in one corner,
and they're all just where,
like I'm just gonna take
myself and go somewhere else
and see what I can achieve
and I can be around people
that are people that I can
feel more comfortable around,
you know what I'm saying?
- And that's what sports did for you?
- And that's what sports did for me.
So I started working with the Northwest,
and that was a great, he never
worked with a model before,
and I was their
spokes-model for two years,
and most likely continuing.
Got to do amazing things,
like throw opening pitches
the Cubs and Mets games, and, you know,
just travel around, go to the
Superbowl, talk to people.
People that are involved in the
sports world are incredible.
I think that there's just this true,
I mean, I don't wanna, I'm
going on a sports rant.
Excuse me.
- That's 'cause I set you up for that.
- Oh, it's okay to go on? (laughs)
- Well, let me cut you off, 'cause,
my fans know I love to do that.
How devastated are you that Jimmy Butler
is now in Minnesota, not in Chicago?
- [Erin] Dude, Jimmy Butler is my boy.
- [Gary] You're crushed.
- Yes, I'm so crushed,
I hit him up on Twitter
and I produced this horse game with him,
through Sports Illustrated, and he is,
I just was wat, like, that, that season,
like, he captivated me,
and I was just, like, I mean,
since Michael Jordan
I never really had some--
- Let's be very careful
with throwing that name around here.
I hate him with all my heart.
- You don't like Jimmy?
- [Gary] No, no, Jimmy's fine-ish,
but I hate Michael Jordan.
- (gasping) Really?
Oh my god, please tell
me, I love divisive--
- Well, I'm a Knicks fan,
and I hate Michael Jordan.
That's a perfect segue, Andre?
- Yeah?
- Damn.
- Yo, yo, this is Andre
Mack, a.k.a. Mouton Noir.
I make wine from the Pacific Northwest,
and I'm excited to be here today.
- So, Andre, hold on, I mean, listen,
let's get a little bit deep here.
You're the real wine guy here.
I played wine once in a while, but, like,
why don't you give us a two-minute story
of, like, your rise to fame, because,
we met a long time ago.
When I thought of this concept,
your name bubbled to the tippy top.
I mean, I interacted with hundreds
of thousands of wine people,
but, you were at number one
on the list of who I wanted
- We got history,
we got history, no totally.
- To be here today
so, tell everybody--
- So my background is restaurants.
I worked as a sommelier for many years.
- Hold on, real quick, Andre,
I'm sorry, we're excited.
But we've got the first wine poured.
These are all blind wines.
The first one is a white
wine, we've established that.
We're gonna let Andre tell his thing,
but, like, I could see that Erin was ready
to like, drink it right now.
- She's been behaving herself.
- You guys can smell it,
but do not drink yet.
We're gonna get into the sniffy
sniff and the first taste
in a minute.
- No tasting yet.
- But, we need Andre to be
able to do his thing, go ahead.
- No, no, so I started in restaurants.
My background was in
restaurants as a sommelier,
for many years.
I started in Texas, of all places,
and made my way to the
French Laundry in California,
worked for Chef Thomas Keller,
and then I moved to New York
unsight, unseen, in 2004,
to be the opening sommelier for
the sister restaurant, per se.
And that's where I met Gary.
Gary came in with a group
of purveyors and a friend,
and I was like, who the fuck is this guy?
Like, he just kept
chirping and I was like,
I like this guy, like, I
had never heard of him,
and then, like, I think
he went to the bathroom
and John leaned in and goes, "No, dude,
"this dude sells the most
fucking wine on the Internet."
I was like, that guy?
He's like, "That dude."
And we quickly became friends.
But anyways, that's kind of my rise.
I've been in New York ever since.
I left the restaurant business in 2007,
wanting to continue my
education about wine
and I felt the only way to
do that was to make my own.
So we make about 40,000 cases now, and--
- Are you up to 40,000 cases, man?
That's amazing.
- 47 states, 22 countries.
- [Gary] How many
different SKUs do you use?
- We have about like 13 different SKUs,
but we're SKU-heavy for those.
Our most popular wine is
called Other People's Pinot.
I'm sure you've seen it.
It's got a big ole white
and black OPP on the front.
- You throw a lot of
hip-hop into your wine names
and things of that nature, right?
- Yeah, absolutely, I mean, you know,
I'm just a kid who, I grew up on hip-hop,
and I just happened to
fall in love with wine,
and I just kept thinking,
why not be able to put
those two things together?
It felt like every person I talked to
who was in the wine business,
always got the hip-hop references,
we're always singing those songs.
- [Erin] I'd love that.
- As a Texas boy, I feel
like Scarface hasn't entered
any of your labels just yet.
Don't you think that's
a little disrespectful?
And can we please address that
with one of your next cuvees?
- Maybe we'll do it subtly, but,
they were raw, they were raw.
The ghetto boys in Scarface,
they were really raw.
I don't know if they're
really ready for that.
I think I, tentatively I
had a wine called Ill Na Na,
and some others, that hit
the kibosh on that one, so.
- What, the alcohol and tobacco world
wouldn't let you do that?
- No, no, no, I think it was
more my wife was like, dude.
- You're pushing it too far?
- I think I know what that is, like--
- [Gary] Like, cut that shit.
- Yeah, totally.
- All right, we've
established the four of us.
Let's go into the first wine.
Andre, I'm gonna let you take it away.
What should everybody
be doing at this point?
- Oh wow, you should be
actually looking at the color.
Color can tell you a
lot of different things,
but we have a brown background,
so maybe you wanna hold it over the rug
or maybe a white background.
You just wanna kinda look at the wine.
I mean, we get points for
naming the color of the wine,
so, it's white, right? (laughs)
We know that, we got that right,
take all credit--
- You are crushing it, Andre.
- What do they say?
Hey, you get five points
for writing your name
on the paper, right?
- [Woman] He's the expert?
- It's true, it's true, so look,
let's establish some rules here.
We don't need to guess what
this is, or what you have.
Where I want to take
it for all four of us,
even for us, like, we don't have to guess
what regions it's from, what vintage.
At this point, Andre, it
must be fun for you as well.
Like, we grew up in the wine
world when it wasn't cultural.
Now, because of Netflix and
all these documentaries,
everybody, it feels, has seen Somm
or this, that, or the other thing, so,
even though Andre very
much has those capabilities
and I'm sure guests that
I have on Brown Bags
will have those capabilities,
that is not really where
I'm looking to take it.
Where I'm looking to take it is,
do you like it, what does it taste like,
and maybe, how much do you
think it costs, would be cool.
Can you do me a favor, Trouty,
I know you're in the background.
I don't know what the wines are either.
I know Brandon picked
them from Wine Library.
Can you get him to text
you what the wines are,
and maybe the current mainstream
scores and the price point?
Just so when we have the unveil,
because I'm totally not prepared for this.
- [Erin] Can we guess, like--
- You can guess anything you want.
- [Erin] I would like to know,
like, without telling us,
I wanna know if we know.
- Yeah, of course.
- If it's like, a Syrah
or a Pinot or--
- [Gary] Yeah, I promise
you it's not any of those,
since those are red wines.
- I didn't wanna say
- I'm kidding, I'm kidding,
I'm kidding.
- whites because,
no, I, because, you know,
anchoring, you know.
- Yes, no, no, don't worry.
So, let's sniffy sniff first.
For anybody who watched Wine Library TV,
I call it sniffy sniff because
I wanted it to be funny,
and wanted to be memorable,
but what I really wanted was,
you know, Wine Library
TV, it'll be interesting.
I'll actually ask you your
perspective on Wine Library TV.
It was so important to me
to trick America at scale
into a couple things
that I thought mattered,
which was, one, trust your own palate.
Forget about what Andre and I say, like,
we don't get nervous
about our point of view
on sushi, or a
cheeseburger, but with wine,
we're always looking at the
person that knows the most,
and we have to succumb to
his or her point of view.
I hated that.
I'd like to change that,
that was a big goal of mine.
And number two, we need
to smell wine more.
Like, you guys cannot
imagine how much more
you will enjoy the wine if you smell it.
So let's get the sniffy sniff.
Now, Mary Kate, I don't
want you to be polite
or PureWow while we're here.
I want your schnoz, there
you go, all the way in, yeah.
- That's how you do it?
- It's like, dripping
in white wine now.
- Yeah, yes.
- Are you supposed to wait, Gary,
and let it kind of open
up and keep going back
and smelling it again and again?
- Well, I like swirling the wine,
bringing it up.
- My nose is wet.
- Yeah, yeah, I learned this.
- So yeah, you wanna aerate the wine,
and what Gary's talking about,
most people don't smell the wine.
90% of taste is smell, right?
Think about, like, when you were a kid
and you pinched your
nose 'cause something,
you didn't want to eat your asparagus
or whatever it was, right?
Kind of the same thing.
So you want to actually
slightly crack your mouth.
I'm gettin' a little nerdy
here, Gary, I'm sorry.
- [Gary] I'm listening.
- You wanna crack your mouth a little bit,
and you wanna inhale through your nose
and exhale through your mouth, right?
And that opens up the olfactory senses,
so you get, like, this
better sense of smell, yeah.
So you want, yeah, you wanna smell.
- [Erin] What you just
said, I've never smelled
like that before, in my life.
- Yeah.
- [Erin] That just blew my mind.
- All right, so what do you
- Are they like tasting?
I'm like spillin' over here.
- guys, what are you guys,
what'd you get, don't worry.
- Are we tasting
or not tasting?
- What're you guys getting
on the nose?
Like what are we tasting here?
(sloshing)
- Are you smelling, are
you hearing me smell?
- Yes, it's making up
your smell.
- Oh I thought we were.
- Erin, I know you're
drunk, and that's fine too.
(Erin laughing)
I mean, on the nose thing, like,
for me, the melon and honeydew thing
is coming through on the nose,
which I like.
- I get a little bit of that.
- What are you getting Andre?
- I get a little bit of
canned asparagus, like slightly,
like when you first open it up.
Not that that's a bad thing
or a good thing, but--
- You buy canned asparagus?
- This is what I love.
This is what, exactly.
This is what always
cracks me about tastings.
- I know, I--
- No, my mom used to buy it.
- Yeah, I get it, I get it.
- I'm sorry, Mom.
But my mom used to buy
canned asparagus.
- Now I assume you go
to a good, solid, like, you know,
fresh food farm in Brooklyn.
- Oh you know, feed me
(mumbles), oh totally, yeah.
- So Gary, I don't know
if you know this, my
first job out of college,
I was a whiskey editor, and
I was a 22-year-old girl
who had never drank
whiskey before in her life.
And I'd go to these tastings--
- And you got the job
as the whiskey ed--
- And I got the job.
- Sounds like a real
fucking fine establishment.
(laughter)
- [Mary Kate] The
magazine has since folded.
- No shit, go ahead.
- So, no, I edited a very
smart whiskey person,
but I would have to go on tastings,
and, Andre, this is when I always wanted
to call bullshit on people,
because they'd be like,
"Ah, I smell the pita of the isle of yore
"in Scotland in 1901."
I'd be like, what, I smell alcohol.
- Correct and that's exactly--
- Well that's 'cause
you didn't know shit.
- And that's what I
smelled at the beginning.
Like, when I first started,
- Yeah, me too.
- it was like--
- Wine.
- all I smell is alcohol, like,
I mean, how can you get any
of those things out of that?
- [Mary Kate] But, canned asparagus,
this really hearkens you back
to a canned asparagus moment?
- But these are all moments, right?
When you smell things, it's
supposed to take you back
and when I tell people,
when you smell wine,
talk about what it makes you think about.
Like, he was famous for saying,
"This is like Big League Chew."
Well, you know--
- 'Cause it was.
- obviously it didn't taste like that,
but, like, that's what it reminded him of.
When you opened up that pouch,
when you and your boys got into the store
and you opened that pouch--
- That saccharin smell.
- yeah, it's about memories,
like, someone's like,
"Hey, this wine reminds
me of my grandfather,"
and you're like, "So, what
about your grandfather?"
"Yeah, I used to sit on his lap
"and he would smoke a cigar," ah, right?
It's the cedar, you're smelling
the oak on the wine, right?
So, I think it's just more about memories.
It's like when you
smell something--
- Mary Kate, I would
add on that, like, to Andre's point, like,
what really broke me out, I thought,
with Wine Library TV, is that
I really just talked about,
I remember being scared,
to being called out in a blind tasting.
I was in the wine world.
It wasn't like I was
trying to be a comedian
or doing a shtick, so,
I remember being fearful
of people giving me a
glass of wine and saying,
what do you smell, or what do you think?
And so, I was like, look,
I need to go as true,
for everybody who's listening,
in the same way I kind of
call it like I see it stuff,
I did that for wine, in
that I used Big League Chew,
or the way a racketball smelled
to me, or anything else,
because I knew that if I smelt
it again, I could recall it.
And so, the nuances are there,
as they are in coffee and
tea and other alcohols,
brown goods, the flavors are there.
I think to Andre's point,
and to your point, actually,
I apologize, there was a lot of adjectives
and descriptors that were
established by the wine world,
that everybody kept rinsing and repeating,
and I feel like we
forced our ways into it.
Whereas, now, I think,
with the democratization
of Instagram and
personalities and bloggers
and what I started with Wine Library TV,
now that there aren't four or five people
that control everything anymore,
there's been more freedom
in the descriptors,
and I think that's powerful.
- Absolutely, I mean,
people describe wines as banging, right?
You're like, that one is banging.
You're like, oh, wow, okay.
- That makes sense--
- Yeah, see.
- [Mary Kate] Yeah, it does, yeah.
And also just the democratization
of the entry of wine too,
the fact that you have
an OPP, I mean, like,
that didn't exist 15 years ago.
- All right, enough
bullshitting, let's drink this.
- All right.
(slurping and swishing)
- [Erin] How do you drink it, Andre?
I love technical stuff like this.
- [Gary] Carefully.
- Yeah, very carefully,
is that what he said?
Yeah, you just want to, you know, sip it,
maybe pull in some air into your mouth.
If you wanna gargle it, you can gargle it.
All those things make a difference, like,
some people swish it
around in their mouth,
push it through the front
part of their teeth, you know,
all those different things can tell people
something different about the wine.
- It's really, really, really great,
Erin, to like, make sure it hits
as much of your tongue as possible.
So, like, that is something
that you should really,
yeah, you like that part?
- [Mary Kate] Zingy!
- You know, like, like--
- [Erin] I smelled fruit.
I smelled differently today,
I tasted differently today.
- Right, because what happens,
the reason you probably said zingy is,
you probably got more
wine into the back part
of your tongue, which
is gonna kick that in,
and most people never get there.
- [Erin] Oh wow, yeah, my
face, I just like, wow.
- [Mary Kate] Yeah, wine drinking
is not a pretty sport.
- What'd you get flush?
- [Erin] No, it just
was a powerful feeling.
It was really, it was rad, it was...
(Mary Kate laughing)
- So, to me, the one thing that,
for everybody who's listening,
that I highly recommend,
is tasting wine in two ways.
One, if you're like
listening along right now,
just taste your wine, just drink it
in the way you normally do.
And then two, swish it around,
let it hit different parts.
You will be stunned by
how different it tastes.
What will be ironic is, for most people,
the second way usually
will not be as pleasing
because the acidity and the tannins,
depending on a red or white wine,
will be more accentuated when
it hits more of your mouth
and you won't like that
bitterness or acid as much,
and it'll become, for a lot
of people, less flavorful.
- [Erin] I found that with this though,
like, that feeling balanced it.
Like, that, you know, I--
- You liked it, or you--
- This is great.
I love this.
- [Gary] Nobody say what they think.
- Oh my god, I'm just jumping the gun.
- We're gonna need you to leave.
Thanks for coming, Erin,
it's great to catch up.
(laughter)
- Someone's moving on, oh my god,
that's so embarrassing.
- So let's pour this out,
we're gonna move on in a minute.
Like, gather your thoughts on this wine.
Think about it.
- We need cheat sheets
or something to write our notes down.
- Yeah, I mean, there's only five wines.
- Okay I guess I can remember.
- But if your memory's not
basic, you're more than
welcome to take out your phone.
I'm gonna pour the second wine.
Andre, what's been going
on in the wine world?
Like, what's the real kind of,
what's a trend or two
that, for somebody like me
that's not in it day
in and day out anymore,
has emerged in the last couple years?
- Got it, uh, lots more
sparkling wine from America.
- Really?
- Yeah, so you're startin'
to see a lot more of that.
Definitely made in like different fashions
like Methode Champenoise,
but you also have stuff
that's happening Pattonette style,
so you have a lot of that
kind of stuff going on.
Loire Valley varietals are
pretty hot here domestically.
- [Erin] Loire Valley's my favorite.
- Yeah, so you enjoy those?
- That's what I always,
yeah, that's what I look for.
- Wait a minute, so you mean Sancerre?
- [Erin] Just Loire Valley,
but like, Sancerre, yeah.
A Chablis is--
- That's burgundy.
- [Erin] Is it?
Chablis, well, Gamay--
- Erin, we're gonna need you to, leave.
No, I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
- You know what--
(all laughing)
- We're gonna need ya--
- Thanks for playing.
- It's all good.
- It's been really great.
- I'll just slowly
crab walk to the door.
- That's three strikes,
Michael Jordan number one.
(All laughing)
- Absolutely, Rose is something that's--
- That's insane.
that's white hot right now.
- [Mary Kay] It's insane!
- [Gary] That's insane.
Ten years ago, I couldn't sell Rose--
- Absolutely.
- if, like, it came with free money.
Now, it's like, literally culture.
- Yeah, well, and it's just interesting
to be on that beat, you know.
We started making Rose in 2009
and taking it out to
places across the country.
People are like, yeah, whatever.
Like Las Vegas, like,
it's hot as shit there,
and people are like, nope,
because people didn't want to be confused
with drinking white zinfandel.
- That's right, that was a
halo that sat over it forever.
- What's wrong with that, white zinfandel?
- It was two dollars and it
was sweet, and it was garbage,
and old grandmothers drank it,
and nobody wanted to
be associated with it.
- [Mary Kate] It came in like, jugs.
- Yep, and, so now it's
changed, you know, like,
I'm in Minnesota and someone's like,
"Hey, I'm gonna take you to this shop
"that has the most Rosé," and
you walk in, and last year
they had, like, a table
with five of 'em on it.
Now they have two tables full, right?
So it's definitely a genre that's grown,
and I think just now more,
it's more part of popular culture
of celebrities playing
in the field, which--
- What do you mean,
like, Brad and Angelina
when they were together had a Rose?
- Well, them, but then--
- or Fat Jewish?
- Yeah, and then Fat Jewish, like,
so wine is becoming really
more part of American culture,
and that I'm excited about, you know?
I mean, I'm excited about all of it,
but I see a lot of that
kind of stuff happening.
You know, the competition's
a lot stiffer now, right?
There's a lot more people
starting out like I did,
at the beginning, right, you know,
just, like, doing whatever
they can, you know.
I started, it was like,
fucking couch surfing.
Like, wherever I had
free or extended terms
is where I kind of hung my hat.
But you're starting to see
lots of small stuff everywhere,
you know what I mean?
Like, just, you know--
- You mean small producers?
- Small producers, I mean,
we live here in New York.
You can sell anything.
- Yeah, of course.
- But, like, even just across the country,
even the rise of natural
wine, domestic and foreign,
has really really hit New York hard,
and it's trickling out into other states,
but you definitely see that, but,
on the production side, I would say
you're seeing a lot more sparkling wine.
- Mary Kate, what are your readers, like,
when it comes to wine, what's working,
like, what are people paying attention to?
What are some of those more
viral stories through the years?
- Well, definitely Rose, and Rose in like,
any kind of facet they can find it,
so it's Rose cocktails, it's
froze, it's frozen Rose.
But wine is more like
a lifestyle for them,
so wine to pair with your book club,
wine to pair when it's just yourself,
wine to pair with foods,
wine to pair with events,
holidays, I mean, it really is,
they see it lifestyle first, which I love,
because then it means
they're drinking more of it,
but it's more the lifestyle aspect first.
- Wait, they're not nerding out,
they're not studying it,
they're not collecting it,
- No, no, no, no, no.
- they're not trying to
figure out every nuance of it.
- Sure, and like, standard price points,
region, that comes into play, but really,
more like how to serve it and
where and when to serve it,
really is, like, fascinating to them.
I love that.
- Yeah, that's so cool.
- Let's go sniffy sniff
on this.
This has a totally different
nose than the first wine.
This is also a white wine.
- [Erin] It's spicy.
- [Mary Kate] Really, I don't smell that.
- I smell, like, a little bit of vanilla.
- [Erin] Yeah.
- There's a ton of vanilla.
Do you smell that?
- [Andre] Um-hm.
- You got that, Trouty?
Over there in the
bleacher seats over there?
You and Nate with your rivalry?
- [Mary Kate] I really hope
you guys survive today.
- No, there's a ton of vanilla bean
going on here.
- I thought you were gonna say
there's a ton of rivalry.
- All right, let's give it a whirl.
(slurping and swishing)
I'm spitting the wine.
The rest of the crew here is drinking it
directly to the face.
- It's too far for me to grab
so I'll just have a better day
- Erin just finished
her entire glass.
- And be a little drunk.
- I'm just kidding. (laughing)
- Erin and I are gonna roll out of here.
- We're about to talk later,
the second half (laughing)
- I'm changing the format.
- The slurring half?
Since this is audio and not visual--
- He's calling the audible.
- I feel like we're gonna talk
a little bit about the wines now.
So, let's do that.
I don't wanna sway opinions, but,
Mary Kate, we'll start with you.
- [Mary Kate] So, we're not
saying what we liked better,
we're just talking about this wine?
- You're talking about this
specific wine, this white wine.
- [Mary Kate] Mm-hm, so--
- Is it fresh, is it heavy?
- It's definitely--
- Do you love it,
do you hate it?
- I, well, that's rating it--
- Let me start,
I did not like the first wine.
- [Mary Kate] I hated the
first wine, it reminded me
of my grandmother.
- Andre?
- Not that I hate
- Only if I had it
with oysters.
- my grandmother, mind you.
- But off the straight up, it's okay.
- [Gary] Now remember, we're tasting--
- [Erin] What, the
first wine or this wine?
- [Gary And Andre] First wine.
- Just for everybody at
home, Erin, first wine?
Loved it.
- [Erin] Yeah, I like oysters,
that's why, I thought of, oysters.
- (laughing) What about the wine?
- [Erin] Yeah, but it's
like, it's a kind of a wine
that you have at Mary's
Fish Camp, I don't know.
- Understood, understood.
So, one thing for everybody
who's into wine a little bit,
we're tasting these wines
at room temperature.
And so, white wines get really
exposed, you're fine, Erin,
white wines get very exposed
when they're at room temperature
'cause the cold is not hiding it.
I always called it, like, you know,
kind of like the high school beer rule.
Like, when you're drinking Natty Lite,
or Milwaukee's Best, which
is Marcus's favorite,
the beast, like, you get it
as cold as fucking possible
because you don't wanna taste it, right?
So one of the reasons I've
always tasted white wine
at room temperature, is I
actually wanted to taste it,
because if you get this
ice, if wine number one
was dead ice cold, we'd
be like, yeah, okay, cool.
Refreshing!
- I wish you'd explained this before,
because I just thought that this was
like a beat, like, wine tasting,
I was like ah, this wine so so warm!
- No.
- Gary just gave you guys
a pro tip.
That's real shit right there.
- That's great, I love it,
it's so true, it's opened up so much.
- Yeah, you hide flaws in wine by cold,
by chilling them and
making them colder, yeah.
- That first bottle
was like a Capri Sun.
- Cold wines is like
over-make-upped individuals.
You can hide anything, got it?
- Yeah, that's why my
drink is Rose on ice.
(all laughing)
That's my drink.
- Real literally, with cubes?
- [Erin] That's literally my drink, yeah.
- You drink with ice cubes?
- [Erin] Yeah.
- Yeah, I get it.
- It's all good.
- Mollet had a sparkling
wine that they promoted
as with cubes, right?
- Yeah, that's right,
yeah, yeah.
- And has it done well?
- I haven't seen it in the market.
The only way I've seen it is
'cause my boy was one of their,
he was one of their like--
- Homies.
- their ambassadors,
that was going around with it, yeah.
- What do you think about
all the wines in cans
and, like, new formats of delivery?
Like, I'm so amazed.
- Ooh, did you see Underwood?
- Yeah.
- [Erin] I liked that,
they had Rose in a can.
- And Argo, Ramona, like, there's so many
out there now.
- They're actually just
coming out with, I think July
13th they're coming out with--
- [Gary] July 13th was yesterday.
My sister's birthday, happy
birthday, Liz, I love you.
- Aww!
- Happy birthday!
- I have a sister.
- Happy birthday, Liz.
- All right, go ahead.
- Right, yeah, yeah,
your wife, yeah, got it.
- No, my wife's name is Liz,
my sister's name is Liz.
- Got it, I thought
there was two Liz.
- I only like Lizzes.
- There you go, there you go.
- Mary Kate, you need to
change your name.
- I just changed my name
right now, it's also pure Liz.
- Wine in a can is great.
I think it, is it for everybody?
I think wine is this big long train
that you can get on at
any time that you want,
get on and off, so if
you're into wine in a can,
I think it's great.
I like the stuff from
Underwood, I think it's great.
I think the breakout--
- It gets really cold, right?
With the can.
- The breakout is
the wine cooler.
- Can I ask a really
quotidian question?
- [Andrea And Gary] Yes.
- Are you supposed to drink it in the can
like a beer?
- You don't have to, no.
And actually, that's--
- There's no supposed to!
- You're right, you're right.
- If we're gonna get
anything across in Brown Bags Episode One,
it's there's no suppo-,
you wanna fucking funnel
that wine right now?
Funnel it.
- Yeah, that's right.
- You wanna drink it out of a,
like plastic bag?
- Like straw.
- Good.
Like, enough with like,
like, no, but this is real!
We do this with wine, and we don't do this
with everything else.
- Because it tastes different
in a can, that's my point.
- Great!
- [Erin] And it was good.
I like new experiences, though,
I liked, it's drier--
- Tell us about that, Erin.
(all laughing)
- There's, I like breaking the rules,
and it's like, this is weird, but.
- It's dangerous, though, right?
'cause that's a half bottle of wine
and people drink it like beer?
That's the thing.
- Oh, trust me, I'm the
most fun Mary Kate after a can of wine.
(all laughing)
- [Andre] Yeah, but I just think that--
- How bout after three?
- if you wanted to shoot it,
you can, whatever you
want to do today is great.
- When do you switch from the most fun,
to throwing up on people, six cans?
- I haven't thrown up
on people in a while,
but yes, after three glasses--
- Let's get serious here,
let's turn it up, Brown Bags.
- [Andre] Oh, here we go.
- Here we go.
We're only at wine two,
we've got three more to go.
Mary Kate, when is the last
time that you threw up?
- Like, hungover thew up, all right.
- Not like you ate a weird oyster.
- It's, as Gary knows, and most
of the team here now knows,
I do like to go out and have a good time.
And I do have two children,
so those two worlds clash.
- They'll listen to this
eventually, 'cause I'll
be popular with them
'cause I'm skewing younger, but,
for now, they're very young,
so they won't hear this.
- I think Jackson
more than Charlie.
We're worried about Charlie's
entrepreneurial skills.
Yeah, definitely this past year.
I definitely-
- You threw up?
- Oh, for sure!
- Paint us a--
(Andre laughing)
- For sure.
- [Gary] I'm so proud of you.
I, like, I don't say no to a fun time.
Yeah, for sure.
Oh my gosh, it's so embarrassing,
I could probably just--
- In the last 365 days, you threw up
from too much alcohol consumption.
- I thought I just said
for sure five times.
Yeah, I'll text Anna, my
best friend, right now
and see what--
- What the exact date was.
- She knows.
Anna.
- That's pretty amazing.
- What about you?
- [Erin] I don't vom.
- You don't vom?
- No, I don't, no, I'm Irish.
- Yeah, I didn't know that throwing up
was now called vom, but I'm
pretty fired up about that.
Now it's called vom.
- Now we all know
I've contributed something
today. (laughing)
- Opinions are being contributed.
Erin, what do you think
about wine number two?
- Wine number two, hang on.
I mean--
- This is, remember--
- Are we sharing as we go now?
- [Gary] Yes, we're sharing
as we go, I changed the rules.
- [Mary Kate] Oh, I got a little cinnamon.
- [Gary] We're gonna vom
our opinions to each other.
- (laughing) I mean, I rarely meet a wine
I don't like, unless I'm on
American Airlines.
- You're gonna like all five.
Understood
- Like this, I mean--
- [Gary] Compare this to wine number one.
- I mean, I'm kind of
upset that everyone's like,
hating on the first one.
- [Gary] Don't be!
- 'Cause I like the first one.
- You may be a pioneer.
We may unveil it, it might
be one of the highest rated--
- [Erin] Just trailblazing
the white wine today.
- Yeah, what do you think about this wine?
- I think it's all right, I think that--
- [Gary] Is it too soft?
Do you feel like the subtleties
compared to wine number one
and that makes it a little boring for you?
'Cause I see a boring face.
- It's like, spicy, like I
said when I first smelled it.
There's something spicier about
this one than the first one,
and I like, even coffee
too, I like things,
like, I like instant
coffee, and Dunkin' Donuts.
Like, that, do you know what I mean?
There's like, I don't
know if it's like acidic?
I like, when I ask for
wine, I ask for miner,
- [Erin And Gary] minerality.
- [Gary] Okay, Andre, wine number two?
- Wine number two, vanilla, slightly oaky,
some cinnamon.
- Do you like it?
- You know, I think it has its place.
Yeah, it's pretty decent.
- [Gary] But you seem bored by it.
- Yeah, I'm not, you know, I'm not,
My socks aren't blown off--
- Writin' home.
- or anything like that.
- [Gary] Compared to wine number one?
- I found wine number one maybe to be
a little bit more interesting
because it was funky,
right, because it wasn't,
as this wine seems a
little bit more technical
and laboratory-made in that way,
where the other wine
seemed to have, like--
- A little flavor.
- Some savage to it, right?
- Yeah, Mary Kate?
- Some funk to it.
- Understood.
- I definitely like this one better.
This is more my jam.
This feels like
ladies-who-lunch white wine.
Like, this gets the job done,
this can be consumed in mass quantities.
One, that's interesting
that you say that about one,
because I thought at first it was swill,
but now I do have a
little bit more respect
that you say that,
like, I like the vanilla
and cinnamon of this, this
is an easy drinking white,
but now I'm super curious,
because maybe you're right,
maybe one has a nuance there that,
Gary served it at, like,
warm-ass temperature
but maybe chilled, maybe
I'd have a different taste.
- 'cause right now, all
the wines, they taste hot.
The alcohol is really amplified, right?
So that's what we're tasting, right?
- So for me, the good news
is, I have more self-esteem
than Mary Kate, and can
stick to my own opinions.
- Wait, when did you get--
- I wasn't succumbed,
I wasn't persuaded by Andre's,
so for me, I really love
the wine number two,
and don't like wine number one.
I wasn't persuaded by Andre's
charm like Mary Kate was.
- He gave me the love eyes.
- I feel like I'm a very
big fan of wine number two.
I feel like it's interesting
where you're coming,
I'm really curious what wine--
- Should I go back in
and see what Gary's talking about?
- You can do anything you want.
I think what's really
interesting to me is,
as you were talking, 'cause I
respect your palate so much,
I'm like, huh, 'cause for me,
wine number two is so well balanced,
and is it so integrated, fruit, acidity,
structure-wise, or, is it boring?
Like, this is where it gets
sometimes super interesting
with wines, when it's so, and you said it,
this is why this is fun.
It doesn't matter what
angle you come from.
All of us were wildly,
interestingly saying the same thing.
You said it in your way, like,
you like the radness of wine
number one, the spiciness,
you were like basically trying to Erin,
articulate your thoughts
on it, but basically,
what you were saying is, it's seamless,
and either boring or clean.
You were saying that, and you, Mary Kate,
you were saying, it's, you
know, it gets the job done.
People will like it, because
what you were reacting to
was that seamlessness.
Nothing was out of whack.
There wasn't anything too aggressive,
and that either means,
that it's a boring-ass
wine that is too technical,
and it's funny how you broke it down,
and it's kind of like a cliche wine
that like is on supermarket
shelves at Albertsons
and everybody can like it, or,
it means it's like a
white burgundy-like wine
or a producer that's making
a seamless integration.
Now I'm excited to see
what wine number two is.
- I have a question for you.
- Go ahead, let's dump,
we're gonna go to wine number three.
- I have a question about boring
wine versus exciting wine.
See, I don't like cabernet.
Is that what people, is it, is it just,
because it's not boring?
It's like two-
- Well, why don't you like it?
- Because it's so much.
- It's too powerful?
- Yeah, and maybe, like, it
just has a lot happening?
- It's a heavy red wine.
- It's heavy.
Like, I don't like cabernet.
I don't know why it's so popular,
but maybe they're bored by pinots.
- But you know, I think
also, like, cabernet,
a new world cabernet, like, you know it--
- And when he means new world cabernet,
for everybody listening-
- Sorry.
- No, no worries, you
keep doing your thing,
that's what I'm here for.
He's talking about like
Napa Valley cabernets,
like not the cabernet-based
wines from Bordeaux
or even Tuscany, like, new world cabernets
are gonna have a lot of fruit.
They're the Silver Oaks and the Caymuses
and the Harlans that a lot of you know,
if you're into wines, so keep going.
- Yeah, no, but like,
the whole fact is, like,
coming new to a wine, like,
it's made from grapes, right?
It's made from fruit.
Most people, there's an association,
why doesn't it taste sweet?
Why does it not taste this way?
And I think what happens
is, is that you have,
you have something like this.
People are attracted to
something that's overripe
and that tastes like jam, in some ways,
and that's not a bad way.
I think that's how I started.
And the fact of it is, is that, you know,
as Americans, we have a sweet palate.
Right, there's nothing wrong with that.
We invented the cocktail,
during Prohibition,
to cover up shitty booze.
- Yeah, we like sweets.
Erin, are all these,
- I love that, I've never
thought of it like that.
- Are all these impressive
dudes that you date
like, trying to impress you
with, like, high-end cabernet,
and do you feel like maybe
- Oh, I love where
this is going.
- that's why you hate it?
- [Erin] That's where I learned it.
- This is so much better now.
- Did I nail that?
- Yes, you nailed it,
like on the beat.
- I think the first half
of this podcast now goes in the garbage
and we just start here.
- [Gary] Well, yeah, we've
gotten to the vom part,
now we're gonna get to
into Erin's dating life.
- I'm still waiting
for the text.
- Which is gonna be
far more interesting.
But I checked, when you
were saying that, I'm like,
oh, I bet you,
that she's going out
- Oh yes, you're so right.
with these dudes who are
ordering, like, the fucking like,
you know which ones,
Nate's sitting,
I yell at them, I'm like
I don't like cabaret.
- Nate's sitting right
behind you.
- I've told you four times.
- So I was able to see Nate's
face while you were talking,
like, oh, that would be the
bullshit that Nate would pull.
He would buy, like a boring cabernet.
Trouty, I know you
wouldn't order a cabernet.
You're super bougie,
you would order some wine
that would confuse the girl.
She would leave, like, while
she went to the bathroom,
and you'd be sitting there
drinking your Gamay by yourself.
- Gamay, Gamay!
That's my first favorite wine.
- Trouty!
- [Mary Kate] Any girl Trouty dates,
definitely likes Rose in a can.
- No, but Erin, Erin, like, that literally
is how it's hit your radar, the cabernet.
- [Erin] Well, yeah, I mean, like,
that's how I learned about all wine.
You know, my first
boyfriend was Swiss French,
and we for four years
lived in London and Paris.
- Was he much older than you?
- No, no, four years.
- Oh, interesting.
I missed it, I thought it was like 11.
- [Mary Kate] Yeah, I was
kind of hoping for 11.
- I was kinda hoping for like 30.
I was hoping she was 20
- My parents are 11 years apart.
- Yes, yes, yes.
- My parents are
11 years apart.
- Erin, can you just pretend
he is 54?
- Your parents are 11 years apart?
- [Erin] Yeah, they're
kicking, they're going.
They're fine.
- Okay, they're goin'.
All right, wine number three.
What are we, let's sniffy sniff.
- I love it on the nose.
- Sniffy sniff.
- What are you getting on
the nose, the nose itself?
- [Mary Kate] This is like September,
New York Fashion Week, back into New York,
definitely drinking red.
- Yeah see, there you go.
- [Gary] Now you're getting it, Mary Kate.
- All the berries, I love this.
- Andre.
- This like, hits all
of that moment.
- Potpourri at my
grandmamma's house, you know what I mean?
- Oh, totally different.
Some pencil shavings,
some graphite.
- You can definitely smell the--
- [Erin] Graphite?
- You can definitely
smell the sweetness.
- Yeah from like
when you sharpen a pencil.
- It's from my like--
- I like the berry.
- You can smell the sweetness.
- fourth grade
mechanical pencil.
- Absolutely, you'd go into smelling it,
expecting it to be sweet, right?
- 100%, all right,
let's give it a whirl.
- Where do you get
that graphite?
- [Andre] I get graphite on there.
- I get graphite too, actually.
It's, you know what graphite
also sometimes smells like
if you're going through it?
Metallic, it depends on
how you articulate it
as an adjective,
- Yes, a tinny, yes.
- But this almost smells
like you took an aluminum bat
when you were, like, in Little League,
and you had a bunch of strawberries,
and you started smashing the strawberries,
and then you smelled the baseball
bat and the strawberries.
- [Mary Kate] Who does that?
- You should write
- That's crazy.
- children's books.
- [Andre] Gary does it.
- [Mary Kate] Who does that?
- No, this is like you went on a barbecue
and someone gave you a
piece of pie to take home
in aluminum, and then you opened it up.
That's like the normal
thing, versus, like,
the physical violent way
that you experienced it.
- But listen,
let's not suppress the male--
- Delta first class.
- Yeah, like, why are you
suppressing my male, like,
you're being way too
politically correct on me.
Like, why can't I be a boy for a second?
- I have two of you at home,
- I'm sorry, yeah.
- I built Legos this morning.
That's actually baloney,
- Alexa, play the
Imperial March.
- I vomited this morning.
No don't, Alexa, I already
heard it this morning.
- [Alexa] The Imperial
March, Darth Vader's Theme,
by John Williams and
London Symphony Orchestra.
- She's added that.
("Imperial March")
- So the reason this is playing,
is Mary Kate's boys do that with Alexa
every morning, and walk around.
- [Mary Kate] She stopped
because you said her name again.
- Yeah.
Alexa, stop.
So, Erin, what do you
think about this wine?
- [Erin] What do I think about it?
I think, oh, I haven't tasted it yet.
- Well, please taste it, Mary Kate--
- I love it.
- Erin's way behind
and she's been smelling for, you love it.
- [Mary Kate] I love
it, it feels balanced,
this feels delicious.
- Oh my god, I want this wine.
I need to know what this is after.
It smelled amazing, that's
why I didn't stop smelling it.
- [Mary Kate] I think
we just stay here now
for the rest of the day
and just jam this wine,
- What is this?
- and this wine alike.
- It's like, what is it?
- Great business.
- Yeah, no, I think
it's a great wine.
- But this is outrageous.
- I think it's pretty
well balanced, you know.
I'm torn over--
- Is it too sweet for you?
- A little bit.
I'm trying to figure
where that's coming from,
and, you know, so, and
it's reduced, right?
It's like someone took all of that stuff,
cooked it down and it's, like, stewing.
- It's Grenache-y that way, like, right?
- Yeah, no, absolutely.
- So I'm gonna say something
for everybody listening.
Wine number three, and we'll link this
in, like, where we post it up,
this is going to be, I'm not
sure what I think about it.
You notice that I also like it.
If you noticed how I asked Andre
if he thought it was too sweet,
it is a little too sweet, for me,
but I'm weirdly in the
mood for it to be sweet,
meaning, because we're in July,
to me, this is a very intriguing
barbecue wine.
- Yeah, absolutely.
- Like, as soon as I was
drinking, I was like, oh,
you know, like, just BB,
- Oh, with some ribs.
- and like, just easy like, exactly.
Ribs is exactly
what I was getting.
- Salty, salty ribs, yeah.
- That's exactly right, actually.
- [Mary Kate] Also like a manchego cheese.
- If this is under $20, an
I have no idea what this is,
if this is under $20,
everybody who would buy it
would fucking love it.
- [Mary Kate] Oh yeah, if it's under $20,
PureWow will go bananas on this.
- If it's under $20, will you commit
to buying a case at Wine Library?
- Committed, two.
- At full cost,
full profit for me and my family?
- [Mary Kate] Wait--
- Oh, I will, I'm committing,
- A case usually comes
at a discount.
- I will.
- Okay, thank you, Erin.
- [Mary Kate] Erin, I
was in a negotiation.
- Oh sorry.
- No, Mary Kate,
you're out.
- You just, like totally,
the business.
- You're out.
Erin, you're the new
editor-in-chief of PureWow.
Congratulations.
- [Mary Kate] It's
actually called GaryWow.
- GaryWow, relaunching.
- [Erin] I'm buying it
in bulk, Mary Kate.
- Andre, if you were
rating this on a 100 point
scale, where would you go?
- You know, it's, you know, I mean,
I would look at it and probably--
- Don't play to the mic.
- 89, 91.
- Okay, nice range.
Yeah, me, I like this wine.
All right, let's go to wine number four.
- You said what?
- 89 to 91.
- [Mary Kate] I need a new glass.
I don't want to part with this one.
- Just, just pound it, Mary Kate.
You can throw up again.
You can, you can vom.
- I'm still waiting
for the next vom.
- You can throw up again.
- Super vom with us.
- I'm glad that question didn't get
passed my way.
- Gary, do you get hungover?
- I was just like, oh my god.
- You know what's funny?
I never, ever get hungover,
except the weirdest thing.
I, for some reason, get drunk on sake.
I don't know why.
The last seven times I've been drunk,
have been eating at like high-end,
like, Japanese, like, sushi restaurants.
- [Mary Kate] I think I've seen you
at like four in the morning,
and you've never been drunk.
- I don't drink that much.
I'm never drunk, because I
always need to be in control.
I've never done a drug in my entire life.
Like, even the like,
my entire college crew
is all about smoking
14 blunts to the face.
- [Erin] My dad's like that.
- I need to be in control, but
the one thing that gets me,
I don't see it coming.
I, like, keep doing those
little fucking sake shots.
I never feel it, then all of a sudden,
I get into, like, my car to go home,
and, like, the world, like,
New York City goes upside-down on me,
and I'm like, what the fuck?
- [Mary Kate] So wine
doesn't get you drunk?
- I've never gotten,
I'm like never drunk.
- I think it's the size
of the glass, the sake glass.
- It's tricking me.
Wine number four sniffy sniff.
- And you end up actually
drinking more, yeah.
Ooh, Andre's gonna like this.
- [Andre] So, do you have a code word
- And the dinners are longer.
- for being hungover?
At my house, so, we have three
little kids running around,
so we always say, hey, are you dehydrated?
That's our code word for being
hungover, amongst the adults.
It's just more like, hey.
- [Mary Kate] There's nothing
worse in life, in life,
than being hungover--
- What about murder and rape?
- with a three-year-old.
Nope, nope.
- Okay.
- [Mary Kate] Okay, well, Jesus, now--
- Well I'm just asking, you just said
there's nothing worse--
- The murder, I would say no,
but then the next, I mean--
- So, wait, you're saying on the record,
'cause we'd like to use this
in like a piece of content,
that being hungover is worse than murder.
Can we put that as official
press release on PureWow?
- [Mary Kate] Do it.
- Okay, good.
Erin, congratulations, you're the new,
sitting, editor in chief. (laughing)
- The offer still stands.
- All right, what are we
getting on this nose?
This is smokey.
- Apples.
- Apples?
- Yeah apples fresh cut apples
- Oh gross, I don't like.
- You don't like this?
- I don't like it either.
- [Erin] No, it smells,
it smells like vom.
- I love this.
- It does smell. (laughing)
- I like it, it's just funky.
- I love it, I love it too.
- That's why I like it, yeah.
- Yeah, it's super funky.
- Trav, you love it, right?
- It smells like
stinky cheese.
- It's smokey.
- It smells like a pig farted.
- It has this fart
smell to it.
- It smells like stinky,
moldy cheese.
- Yeah, yeah, it does.
- Smell it again, it is farty,
it's very barnyard.
- It smells like a guy
I sat next to on the subway.
- Erin, you're super, like,
Chicago farm girl.
- [Erin] Oh, no, no, I'm
just, like, you know.
- Like, this is like, you went to Iowa.
- [Erin] I'm not scared.
- You're not, okay, I
understand you're not scared.
- [Andre] But no one wants
to drink a fart, though.
(laughing)
- I prefer fart over fruit.
- [Mary Kate] This smells like
no air conditioning.
- Only in my wine.
- Yeah, only in my wine, but--
- [Erin] But guys, it's really wine?
Is this a joke?
- It's super earthy.
No, this is super earthy and raw.
Mary Kate?
- This smells like no air conditioning,
New York City subway, next to, like,
someone who might've just vommed.
- No, this is not BO, and everybody knows
what body odor smells like,
this is not BO.
- No body odor,
no this is fart.
This is different than--
- This is legit cow farm shit.
- Yeah, this is real.
- This is Iowa,
you've stepped into, like, a pig shit.
- Is that peat?
You've stepped into it,
you're trying to clean up your boot,
and you smell the fart,
like, you smell ...
- It's more TOR.
- [Mary Kate] Can you,
Andre, can you clean up this,
like, I'm confused.
- But that's...
- [Gary] Taste it now, wait, taste it.
This is where it gets interesting.
Now taste it.
- It's great.
- So, we farted in your
face, but now taste it.
- [Erin] I love you.
- That's the new name for
the podcast, by the way.
It comes after sloppy seconds.
- [Erin] Okay, I get it
now, I get why you taste,
you smell, and then you taste.
- Right?
- [Erin] That was a story.
- So, Erin, tell us the
story that you just consumed.
- We got, we got farted, someone...
We stepped in cow shit,
went to clean the boot,
got farted on.
- [Gary] Yes, and then you
drank it, and what happened?
- Then you got Febreze, man.
You got some, like--
- [Gary] You got the sour cherry?
- [Andre] Sour cherry but there's
some potpourri at the end.
- Yes, no, I was thinking
of, it was a lavender.
- [Andre] Someone sprayed in
the bathroom after they went.
- It's a cherry, it's
cherry, it's beautiful.
- I just want everybody to know,
we're on wine number four,
I spit the other three,
I'm already fully done
drinking this glass.
- [Erin] This is amazing.
- Do you love it?
- [Erin] Yeah.
- It freaks you out that
it could smell like this,
but taste like that.
Mary Kate?
- It's amazing.
- [Mary Kate] I really, this is like
throwing my world a little bit.
- Did you have a boyfriend
that farted on you,
because he thought he
was like a fratty dude,
but you kind of were really
into it because he was hot?
That's what this wine is.
Farted, but it was delicious.
- [Andre] Wow!
That was never my approach,
that was never my approach.
- Well, that's because you and I
did not live the life of these two ladies.
That's why, I was trying to,
I'm trying to use my empathy here.
- I like guys that fart.
- Brown Bag episode
two is gonna be, like,
Terry Gross and, like, the
most serious wine tasting
in the world, because this
has gone so off the rails!
- I'm gonna lose all my
subscriptions on this podcast.
This is the end of the
Gary V. Audio Experience,
and Wine Library, shut down.
Andre, you've been growing
from zero to 40,000 cases.
You're going back to zero--
- I know absolutely
- After this podcast.
Andre, what do you think about this wine?
- [Andre] I dig the wine.
I like that it's funky,
it's not cookie-cutter.
There is, like, this P-funk, sour cherry,
great acidity in the wine, not over-oaked.
- Not oaked at all.
- Yeah, so it just
feels, it feels natural.
- What kind of grape do you think this is?
I know we haven't gone there.
- Oh, shit.
- [Mary Kate] I wanna
know all of what we think.
- You know, I don't know, maybe...
- I'm struggling with it.
- Maybe from a cool
climate like cabernet franc,
or something like that.
- I'm struggling with it.
Trouty?
- [Trouty] I know what it is.
- Oh, you know, because you're out.
You know, I'm struggling
with it a little bit.
The floral aspects of this
wine, are intriguing to me.
- Would a cabernet franc be floral?
- It could be.
- It could be more vegetal.
- I mean tangy veggie, yeah.
- Yeah, it's usually vegetables.
That's why I don't think--
- Yeah, and that's kind of
what I'm getting a little bit, too.
- But, to his point,
he's probably thinking,
he definitely doesn't think,
excuse me, that this is
Loire Valley cab franc,
but he could think it's
new world cab franc,
if he's saying that, right?
So, like, go back,
actually, now I'm recalling
because I'm ADDed out.
Domestic sparkling wine?
What's happening?
You like that, D-Rock?
That was like 40 minutes ago.
- [Erin] Why is it, why?
- Why is that weird?
- That last interesting thing
was, like, 10 years ago,
when I was in it, like, Gruet, New Mexico,
but, like, what's
happening, what's happening?
- [Andre] Yeah, so, but
now what you have is,
like now you get, like-
- Or is this your, are you nerd,
do you have a prop, are
you, is this your agenda?
- [Andre] No, no, no, no-no-no-no-no.
- I feel like you're doing
wine nerd agenda, okay.
So, what has happened in
the last 24, 36 months
that's popped in the wine
world, sparkler-wise?
- What's happening now is, you have more,
mobile bottling lines?
That people are coming down
and helping with that process.
A good friend of mine just
started a company doing that,
but you just see it.
No, I mean, you know-
- I'm sure, I know you.
But what, has there been
a domestic sparkling wine
that's caught the attention
of the American consumer,
recently?
- Well, but, see, I wouldn't say consumer.
I'm on the, I'm on the gate-
- Nerd side.
- I'm on the gate, I'm
on the gatekeeper level,
yeah, right, yeah.
- No, no, Nate, nerd side.
- Ha, yeah.
- Okay, what's caught
the nerd's attention?
- Absolutely, which means-
- What?
- It's, which is sparkling.
- Who, in the US?
- Oh, um...
- That freaked me out.
- Shit, man.
- Anybody?
- I'm at a loss for words.
- Yeah, I fucking got you, motherfucker.
I think people get bored
and they wanna pioneer.
- Give it to me before you
leave, because I'm curious.
- [Andre] No, dude,
everyone, like, I mean,
that's what people are-
- Well, actually, Andre,
I'm sorry, because I'm being selfish now.
- [Andre] Go ahead.
- What's happening in the
wine scene in New York,
supplier-wise, restaurateur-wise,
who's the hottest sommelier
in New York right now?
- [Andre] I don't know.
- You're out of that game too?
- [Andre] Well, the fact of it is,
is that I'm only here for the weekends.
- Oh my god, there's more?
I can't.
- [Gary] So is there,
well, okay, but you...
- [Andre] So, like, who's killing it,
I think, you know-
- You're smart, come on.
- I think that, like, you know,
a lot of sommeliers are
coming into their own.
I think sommeliers are
more entrepreneurial
than they ever have been in the past.
And I think, and I totally agree with you,
I think that, like, just more people
are more entrepreneurial overall, right?
- So I must still be like this.
- Dude, you ...
- I need to re-enter,
this is, you know what?
This is fun that I'm doing this.
I need to re-enter the
game, because the truth is,
like, when I did Wine Library TV,
people thought I was
a douche bag at first.
- [Erin] Why?
- Because it was so different,
because I'm a little bit aggressive.
Like, I don't know, Andre,
this is actually a good segway.
What was happening when-
- The show wasn't for them,
and that everybody thought it was for you,
and the thing of it is, is that,
and I actually tell people,
granted, there's gonna be some kid
that's gonna come work for you,
that got into wine from
watching this guy's show.
It's just not for, it's like,
you can watch it for entertainment value,
but, like, for everybody, it's like,
"Oh, he's like jammin' wine,"
"he's talking about wine this way."
But all the younger kids are gonna come,
and there's people here,
now, in New York City
who are running wine programs,
that got into wine from watching his show.
And like, and people gotten all in a huff
and a fuss about it, but-
- This was 2007.
First of all--
- Oh, that could make sense
because before--
- It was 2007.
It was 10 years ago.
- That's before I was introduced.
That's, like, the year that, you know,
I was started, like,
moved to New York City
and, you know, it's like the art world.
It feels uninviting, it
makes you feel stupid.
Which is, like, I mean, I feel,
I'll be honest, I feel stupid today.
But, that's what even still,
I've been drinking wine,
and I now, I know my way around wine,
I know my favorites, I know, like...
- [Gary] What is your favorite?
- I mean, I'm...
- Don't feel, like, own it.
- Oh, I'm own, I just, I'm
like four deep right now
(laughs) in these wines.
I'm like, gimme a second.
- We are on wine number five.
What are your favorites, though?
- Are we talking about
wines or her ex-boyfriends?
- Both.
- (hiss)
- [Gary] Favorite boyfriends,
let's actually switch it up.
- No, no, no, I mean,
that's like a nightmare.
They're like The Village People.
(all laughing)
- Alright, favorite wines.
- I love natural wines.
- [Gary] You do.
- I love that cloudy, unpredictable...
I like the story, like if I was a wine,
I'd be, I would be a natural wine.
- Oh, new question: if you
were a wine, what would you be?
- [Gary] Mary Kate,
favorite wine, right now.
Or recently.
- Rosé in a can, and then after that?
A chilled, very cold rosé, I'm kidding.
- [Gary] You're not a
big wine person, right?
- No, I'm a huge wine person.
How about, like, a petite Syrah.
- Petite Syrah, very cool.
- [Mary Kate] Something I
can drink at home by myself.
- [Erin] I love Syrah!
- [Andre] She's on another level (laughs)
- [Gary] You should be Syrah sisters!
- [Erin] I agree with you.
- I love that the most.
- [Erin] I just discovered it...
- [Mary Kate] And we're
gonna leave right from here
and get tattoos that say "Syrah Sisters"
and we'll never regret them.
- [Gary] It's still 11:29 AM.
All right, let's sniffy sniff here.
- I'm so drunk.
- Wait, no, what's your ...
- I'll tell you in a second.
- Yeah, what are you?
I have been really into Nebbiolo.
I'm drinking a ton of Barolo, like,
I had a 90, last night, I had a 96 Vietti,
single vineyard Barolo.
I think Barolo is so underpriced,
for what it delivers.
Burgundy, seven-
- What does it deliver?
- When I use that, I use
it as a slang term for,
what is the quality of that wine,
in comparison to all the
other wines in the world...
- What are you tasting
when you say quality?
That's what people get,
that's where people lose you.
Because I don't know what you mean.
I wanna know what you mean,
because you know what
you're talking about.
- Every single person
that's thinking right now,
think about the thing
that you consume the most.
Soda, hamburgers, bourbon, candy...
- Chewing gum.
- Like, for example, cola, right?
For everybody 40 and older,
when we used to drink cola,
now all you kids drink water
because you're healthy as
shit and you all look great.
Especially with filters
and angles on Instagram.
So, when we drank cola,
it's so easy for me
to taste the difference
between Coca-Cola, Pepsi,
RC Cola, and cola that's
private label, ShopRite shit.
Right?
It's because I drank so much of it.
Like, cupcakes, I like them a lot.
So it's super easy for me to be like,
"oh, this is the good cupcake,
this is a shit cupcake."
But if it's the first
cupcake you ever had,
you don't have context.
So everybody right now,
while you're listening,
close your eyes and think about
the thing you consume the most,
and now tell me, in
that category of thing,
do you feel like you understand
what is good and what is
not, the answer is yes.
You have a very good sense that
this piece of pizza's good,
and this is not, this is, this isn't.
That's how I think about wine.
I consumed so much that
I have so much context
that for my own palate, and
I'm confident in my own self,
this is good wine, this is not good wine.
To me, Barolo is super interesting
because it has the nuances
and characteristics
and complexity of pinot
noir and burgundies,
but it has the fruit and the power
of the things that I like about Cabernets
and other varietals.
I think it's the perfect middle,
and because the wine critics don't carry
as much weight anymore, nobody's able
to make Barolo super overpriced
by giving everything a hundred points
like used to be able to.
And so I think Barolo has
found this really sweet spot
where it's not being
auctioned off in Hong Kong
and these things.
I think it is the perfect wine right now
where if you buy an $80 Barolo
from a really good producer,
I believe you're buying a
$400 Burgundy, Bordeaux,
or cult California wine,
and that's why I love it.
- [Erin] Well, you heard it here.
- [Andre] There you go.
- [Gary] That was good.
- [Mary Kate] That was fantastic.
- That reminded of some of the OGs.
You like that, right?
Seth, you were super impressed,
Seth, you were looking at me
in a totally different way.
You're like, 'wait, he
knows other things too!'
That's what's happening
with you right now.
Iris?
- [Iris] Yeah?
- Okay, good.
Good, all right, let's
get into wine number five.
Let's sniffy sniff.
- Seth soon will be like the bartender.
- [Gary] He really looks
like the Andy Cohen,
Seth, take your shirt off.
No, Seth, really, take your shirt off.
- [Erin] We have a sound mixer in here.
I don't know if it's ...
- [Gary] Seth is cute, actually.
- [Erin] I might have
a little crush on Seth.
- Erin, you like Seth?
- [Erin] Yes.
- [Gary] Dude, a supermodel
just said you're cute.
This is the greatest
day of your life, Seth.
I'll be very honest with you.
I don't know enough about your life,
but I'm gonna save you time.
This is the best fucking day of your life.
Go find one of Erin's
ridiculously hot pictures
on Google, take a screenshot,
text your buddies,
and be like, 'dude, go to 54 minutes'
'into podcast number one
of Brown Paper Bags.'
Like, this is the great
moment of your life.
- [Mary Kate] This might
get cut, though Seth,
so, just keep it for yourself. (laughs)
- No, no, we don't edit.
You don't understand, do
you understand anything?
- Pretty much, no.
- [Erin] Gary, I think
about that all the time.
When I, like, literally every day,
this not editing thing that you do...
- I don't edit shit.
- [Erin] Because you,
something about who you are,
it makes me sit and question, like,
how come I'm not that, like, how come,
why am I with, like, because
that's a power, you know?
- Honestly, that's the reason
I became so attracted to you.
I think for, especially in your world,
I think you are super unedited.
- Oh, really?
- By comparison to your craft
and the other individuals in your world?
- [Andre] They would probably never say
they eat Dunkin' Donuts, right?
- [Gary] Oh, it's so intense.
Like, Erin's a real person.
- Oh really?
I don't know how to be different.
- [Gary] You know everything,
you're a real person.
- Oh, I am, yeah.
I'm a real boy!
(all laughing)
I just don't know how to be different,
but I get very, I'm shy, so it's like I...
Like, if I'm told to, even for
work, take a video of myself,
and post on Instagram,
like, that's gonna, I can't.
- Erin, are you, you know,
let's talk about that for a
minute, because obviously,
we're reminded of, like, the
people that listen to this,
it's not about wine.
A lot of them are...
- It's about getting us drunk.
- Social brand, entrepreneur, dot dot...
- And then talking.
- Are you in your zone the most
when you're being photographed?
Like, are you, like, that
is a strength of yours.
Like, you couldn't have
had the career you've had.
- Back to sports.
- When you're shy, I
know you a little bit,
so like, when you're shy in
real life, this and that,
but when it's game time, right?
Like, when you're in a Victoria,
like, you're shy, yet, Victoria's Secret,
like, outfits, are not shy type stuff.
When the camera, when D-Rock comes around
and you see that camera ...
- I'm a killer.
- Yeah.
- I know that.
- That's fucking interesting.
- But that's sports.
Like in the parameters of
the rules, what you're doing,
if you put me in a space,
I don't see anyone.
I can just move, it's like some people,
it's also jazz musicians
I think have this,
like, I was watching, I'm
cake guys, it's the wine, but,
if you get back to the point, it's like,
some people have their creative outlet
is their physical person
in time and space,
and it's kind of, you can,
I can just feel my body.
Like, whenever I played,
whenever I was practicing,
if a coach told me what
I did wrong with my shot,
I could, every time, I
could immediately change it,
with him just telling me.
- Because you're attached to your body.
- [Erin] Yeah, something, it's kinetic.
And so, that happens when I'm not involved
with, like, I'm just doing my thing.
But then you make it, I don't know.
I don't wanna film myself.
- I understand.
- You know, it's a
completely different thing--
- Andre, where's your,
like, if that's it for Erin,
like, that zone, what is your number,
your an entrepreneur, you've
built this real business.
You've been a sommelier at
the high pressure cooker
of Thomas Keller
restaurants, but if you took,
you're a dad of three, like, in full life,
where's your zone?
- I think just in the
moment, with other people.
I think this is still a people business
and that's why I get
on the plane every week
to go to a place to meet these people.
Not so they can say that they know me,
but more so I can say that I know them
and I think, no one wants to
do business with an asshole.
You generally wanna like those people,
and people give you money or invest in you
or do different things because
they like you as a person.
- [Gary] So your warm
heart charisma, kindness...
- Yeah, I'm out on the front lines.
- [Gary] You feel that's
been your offense.
- Yeah, I think so.
- You feel like you've been
able to build a real brand.
- Yeah, I can walk into
a room and start talking
to people right away...
and that wasn't always a strong suit.
- You developed it.
- I mean, I had to
figure that shit out, right?
- [Gary] Mary Kate?
- Story, like, I get, I get story.
- [Gary] You see
something and you're like,
'oh, that's a story.'
You look at Seth's face, and you're like,
you can figure out the story.
- I have an entire...
- So let's work with Seth.
What is the story with Seth?
- Ready?
I won't even look at Seth.
- [Gary] Oh, you're not
even, you're like a gangster.
Guys, I know you're listening.
Mary Kate is a gangster.
She's not even looking at Seth.
- [Erin] She's such a gangster.
- Let me tell you a couple
things that are happening.
She's not looking at Seth.
Seth is fairly red at this point.
So let's just keep this
going, go ahead Mary Kate.
- Okay.
I would know Seth's entire
history within five minutes.
I'm not kidding.
My husband always says, he's like,
"You flirt with the world
because you ask everyone"
"a thousand questions."
- You are very flirty.
Erin, do you feel her flirtiness?
- Mary Kate is one of a kind, seriously.
But no, yes.
- [Gary] You guys hung out in the Hamps,
throwing a peel-out party.
What have you, what happened there?
- Mary Kate is awesome.
- Did you flirt
with Mary Kate?
- Yeah.
- I love people,
yes, I love people so much.
- Did I?
- I love people so much.
- Yes you do.
- Yes, full-body hugs.
- It's part of the charm then, flirting.
- I love people so much,
and I love their stories.
and I can do it from a business end,
so I can look at a proposal and be like,
you lost the narrative here...
- You know, I've been
very impressed with you.
I thought, when I bought PureWow,
that I would fire you pretty quickly.
- [Mary Kate] Same.
- Yeah, you thought you'd quit, I mean.
- [Mary Kate] I actually have another job.
It's on the water market.
Do you know The Dodo?
- (laughing)
When's the first time we met, Mary Kate?
Do you know?
- Maybe in Austin?
Not in New York.
- [Gary] In either
Cannes or Austin, right?
Maybe three years ago?
- And Cannes was the
first when we went like,
knee-to-knee, like--
- We hang out last.
- [Gary] What was funny is--
- No, because it was--
- Two Cannes ago,
when I already was negotiating,
did you, you didn't know yet, did you?
- No.
- Two Cannes ago?
- Three Cannes ago, we hung out.
Two ago, Ryan told me, and--
- [Gary] This one we were
together, as a team, dominating.
Okay, your superpower, the story.
- The story, I just--
- [Erin] I wanna know what that means.
How did you guys both
know what that means?
What's your superstory?
that's like, a noun.
- Because, I know, but I
just, I love, I love...
- [Gary] Is story a noun?
I'm terrible with grammar.
- I'm skilled, but my skillset
is like, telling narrative.
- [Gary] By the way, I'm
sorry to interrupt you
because I like to do that.
For everybody who's listening right now,
for future Brown Bag episodes,
I highly recommend fast-forwarding
the first 45 minutes,
because the back end, the fourth quarter,
is where all the shit gets good.
Go ahead, Mary Kate.
- My dad was a longtime ad guy,
and I remember, like, forever,
being, like, entranced with commercials
in 30 seconds telling this, like,
emotional tie of a story,
and at the same time,
I was the biggest reader,
and I remember staying in bed
on Saturday mornings when,
like, all my brothers,
I'm the youngest kid, all
my brothers would be, like,
the house would be like, vibrating.
I'm the only girl, four boys.
- That's like my mom.
- That's the narrative.
- She was a reader, too.
- And I would stay in bed and just, like,
pummel through books,
like, chuck 'em aside.
And, I just, like, Seth's story, like,
I'd start at his, like, his tats,
like, what those numbers mean,
and I would then-
- What do they mean, Seth?
Shh, Mary Kate.
- [Seth] It's the add of the house
that both me and my father grew up in,
in Bayside, in Queens.
- [Gary] Yeah, I already
like Seth already.
- And then I would say,
like, who in your family...
- [Gary] Seth, this is gonna be
the greatest day of your life.
- Seth, Seth, who in your, did your,
are you close to your mom?
- [Seth] Closer with my mom than my dad.
- Okay, did she like that
you got those tattoos?
- [Seth] Didn't mind them.
- Why, does she have any tattoos?
- [Seth] No.
- Do you have any other siblings?
- Interesting.
- [Gary] That was a breakthrough moment.
- Now we got him, now we'll go deep.
And I just, Seth and I
will be best friends.
- [Gary] Dude, you got chills?
- What the numbers, Seth?
What are the numbers?
- [Seth] Ah, it's coordinates, so it's...
- [Erin] Dude, I was looking
at Wikipedia last night
and thinking, why do they
put the coordinates on here?
Like, who is looking at this?
- [Gary] Fucking Seth.
- You guys can talk about this later
over a cab franc?
- Fine bottle of cabernet sauvignon.
All right, wine number five.
Sniffy sniff.
- [Mary Kate] I already drank it.
- What do we got?
Andre Mac.
- Smells a little bit soapy,
potpourri, aromatic...
- Soapy is so right.
- He always says potpourri.
- Well, listen, potpourri
is, to his defense,
potpourri is easily the,
there's so much floral aspects to wine,
that whether you associate with potpourri,
whether you associate
with flowers.
- You can break it down now.
- You're gonna use the term.
- But don't you think
potpourri is like, dusty
and hard and crackly,
where floral is like,
- More vibe.
- Blooming and soft?
- This is where the way
you describe things matter.
Go ahead, Andre.
- [Andre] But what happens
is that it gives off,
it's a more potent, more fabricated,
like, perfume odor,
- Okay, that makes
sense to me now.
- And that's what
I'm talking about, going
here, not, when I say floral,
yeah, I do recognize something soft
and maybe more natural.
This doesn't, even though,
it reminds me definitely
of, like, potpourri,
and we don't break it down any.
- Erin, favorite social network.
- [Erin] Social network...
- [Gary] Your favorite app.
- Oh, well...
definitely Twitter.
- [Gary] Really?
- Yeah, I love, I mean I love comedians,
and I love writers.
- You know what's true about your Twitter?
The first time we engaged was on Twitter.
- I meet everyone on Twitter.
- What's crazy about that is,
your Twitter profile picture,
I thought, this is not a joke,
this is a funny thing to say,
when you engaged with
a piece of my content,
and I'm like seeing it, like, as I do,
I thought you were a media company.
Like, you have like some...
what is your picture on Twitter right now?
- It was, it was after the election.
I don't know, I like, hadn't slept.
- [Gary] Yeah, what is that?
What is that, Nate?
- I don't know, I made some weird--
- It's like a woman holding a flower?
- I was just
- All I remember is like--
- [Erin] No the back, you have to
see the background.
- I was like,
this meme account likes my content.
That's literally what I thought.
- [Erin] Oh, that's cool, I would
love to have the--
- And then I was like,
who's this person?
And then I googled, I'm like, what?
I'm like, if I was a
model, I would definitely
not put this weird
fucking bullshit picture
as my Twitter account.
- I hadn't slept!
- [Mary Kate] Probably want
to redirect her friends
not to see her Twitter.
It's like watching the
news too much, you know.
It's just sleepy, and I was like...
- So Twitter's your favorite.
Andre?
- [Andre] Instagram.
- Yeah, you've been doing
damage on Instagram.
I've noticed you've, I've
been watching you for,
you know, it's funny that
we're doing this together.
We haven't talked in a long little while.
- Not in a long time.
- And we used to hang out quite a bit,
based on my hangout style, which never.
- Guys, what happened, with you guys?
- I got busy, I got busy, 100% my fault.
- No, I think we all got busy.
- Guys, this isn't a podcast,
this is an intervention.
- I got married at a diner.
And the ball dropped, so he signed it.
We got married in a diner,
signed the certificate,
at midnight.
We toasted with chocolate shakes,
and we went to Gary's house for a party.
- [Gary] And played Monopoly.
- And the ball dropped,
everybody celebrated with us,
and then we had like a cliche honeymoon.
- Is it weird to ask what Monopoly?
- Like, real Monopoly.
No, we played, listen, my life
is about competition.
- I'm scrabble, I'm Twitter.
- Like, all I'm thinking
about right now is,
everybody is listening, I'm like,
they'd better like me the
most of these four people.
Like, I am super competitive.
- Oh, are you?
Oh, should I step down?
- All the time,
we're like, hanging out,
and he'd say--
- You don't need to step down,
I'm dominating you.
- He'd say, "Where's the boardgames at?"
He goes, "There's too
many people in this room."
- [Mary Kate] I think it's kind of
the me and Andre show, right?
- I barely even, what's your name again?
- [Mary Kate] Exactly.
I'll see myself out.
- So, you've done a really good job, like,
for me, it's really been fun,
because I feel like in a lot of ways,
you've picked up a torch that I left.
- Dude, I listen to you.
So this dude shows up to my
house for a blind tasting,
so we have all these people coming.
He rings the doorbell, he shows up,
and he's got a bottle
of Barolo in one hand
and he's got a bottle of
Cristal in the other hand,
and he's at the front door, and I'm like,
"Dude, it's a blind tasting," right?
It's like, everybody knows
what the fucking wines are.
So we're like, okay, so
then we call to the store,
and we're like, "hey, we're
doing a blind tasting"
"at the house, this is the budget,"
"can you brown bag all the
wines and bring them over?"
And so while we're waiting, he says,
"Hey, is this your laptop?"
We're in my kitchen, and he flips it open
and he starts fucking
typing and shit on it,
and I'm like, blown away.
Like, first and foremost,
what retail wine dude has five IT guys?
Like, I just couldn't understand that.
Like, I was like, he must know
something that I don't know.
And then you flipped open
the computer and you're like,
showing me all the people
who had visited the site,
and talking about, like, Wine Library,
these are all the hits I'm
getting, and I was like,
I should probably pay
attention to this dude.
And it's, you know, I'm on Twitter
because you said be on Twitter.
- I remember.
- Right, and you were
like, "Dude, no-no-no."
I was like, "I'm on it,
"what the fuck am I supposed to be doing?"
He's like, "Join the conversation,
hashtag chardonnay."
- You've done such a nice job.
- So, I take a lot of lead of seeing
what you guys have been doing,
and trying and apply it
in my field, in my world.
It's been fun to experiment.
To be honest, that's what
keeps it fresh and new for me,
because getting on the road
and going to see people,
that's really fun, but,
like being able to--
- Yeah, you've done
a really nice job.
- To document and create that,
and the people that you
pick up along the way,
that follow you, and you get it.
People, you know, you're not the kid from,
you know what I mean?
You're the wine guy to a
lot of the wine people.
You were this wine guy
that was in New Jersey,
but to thousands and millions of people,
you became an inspiration to those people,
and the people back
there did not understand.
They can't get it, you
know, you know, you know.
- I know, I know
- Yeah, totally, I mean like,
I think that you make all the, like,
I think all the social
networks need someone
that make it look positive and interesting
and inspiring and, like highbrow.
Just, no one else is doing that like that.
- [Gary] This has become my
favorite part of the show.
Mary Kate, what would you like to say
about my awesomeness?
- I really like your new haircut.
- Thank you
- Everybody's like,
pumping his head up.
- Seth?
I'm the greatest boss you've ever had?
- Ever.
- Trouty?
- [Trouty] You're great.
- Nate?
- [Nate] Yeah.
- You guys are losers
- Okay, Iris?
- [Iris] The awesomest.
- Great, my man?
- [Gary's Man] Yep?
- Yep, D?
- [D] Of all time.
- All-time, listen, I think I want to know
what your favorite social
network is, Mary Kate.
- A thousand percent, Instagram.
- Thousand percent Instagram.
- A thousand percent, bullish on Insta.
- Why?
- It's the perfect mix.
- Of everything.
- [Gary] Seth?
- [Seth] Instagram.
- [Gary] Trout?
- [Trouty] Instagram.
- [Gary] Nate?
- [Nate] Instagram.
- Boys are visual, guys.
- Iris.
- [Iris] Instagram.
- And Mary Kate, you
just do your own thing.
- [Mary Kate] I'm a boy.
- [Erin] You do your own thing.
- Wow, what a dominance for...
- [Andre] I totally believe it,
and I feel like now that I've
embraced stories a little bit,
'cause I didn't really
fuck with Snapchat.
- Oh, the best.
- But that gives me the broadcast,
kind of element that you
would associate with Twitter.
Right?
- Wine number five.
What do we got, Mary Kate?
- [Mary Kate] (sigh) Just
really moved by today, so far.
- [Gary] How long have you been here?
- Two hours!
- [Gary] No, no, really,
how long have we been?
- It's almost noon.
- I just canceled my day.
- [Gary] I love it this
is so good.
- You guys, we're all going
to my house afterwards
and playing Monopoly.
- [Erin] The theme of this should be
"I Can't Feel My Face When I'm With..."
(all laughing)
- [Mary Kate] Why isn't there music
or air conditioning in here?
- [Gary] The Weekend
will be on episode two.
- [Mary Kate] We almost saw
them, nah, another story.
- [Erin] I like this, I like this.
- I hate this.
- Are we nosy-nosy?
- I think it's boring.
Andre?
- It is boring.
- [Andre] Cranberry, it's kind of blah.
I don't think that it, it
doesn't move me in a certain way.
And I feel like it's a little
bit on the acidic side.
- It is acidic.
- Oh, it was acidic.
- [Erin] Back of the throat, no?
- [Andre] Yeah, and then
you accentuate acidity
on the sides of your
tongue, so if you, yeah.
So if you start to salivate or, like,
the sides of your tongue start to tingle,
that means the wine
is high on acid.
- Andre, favorite wine.
- [Andre] Oh, shit!
Uh...
Second to last.
- Number four.
- Farts.
- [Andre] Yeah, number four.
- [Mary Kate] Farts McGee.
- Number one.
- [Erin] I have to go with number one,
because I was a pioneer...
- You should, I love you!
- And if the price is right, it might win.
- [Mary Kate] Can I
taste number three again?
- It might be the best one.
- Mary Kate,
it's not that serious.
- I'm just, I'm just thirsty.
- What's your favorite wine?
- [Andre] It's not that serious.
- [Gary] Mary Kate, you're
holding up the show.
It's already a fucking hour plus.
People are gonna see the length
of this and be like, "Fuck that."
- [Erin] (laughs) Fuck that.
- It's either two or four.
- [Gary] Two, that's nice.
Which one's your favorite wine?
- Two.
- Okay.
Mine's four as well.
Okay, so four, so let's start
with number five.
- You said four?
- Yeah.
- So, Andre and I are four.
Let's start with wine
number five, we just had it.
And let's see what it is.
Trout, you're ready?
With wine number five?
All right, we're unveiling.
This is the big part of the
show in Brown Bags.
- Can we get Alexa
to give us a drum roll?
- Wine number five.
Mindego Ridge Pinot Noir from Santa Cruz.
I didn't even think
it was a Pinot.
- I liked it guys.
- Let alone, I didn't
think it was a Pinot, bro!
- [Erin] I knew it was a Pinot.
- You didn't think so either, right?
- No.
- It wasn't as sweet.
- How much, Trout, what do you got?
- [Trout] $47.99.
- $47.99, which is about $40 too much.
- [Trout] 93 points, Robert Parker.
- 93 points, Parker, I
think he's losing a step.
- [Erin] You guys, I loved it.
- [Trout] What else do you need to know?
- I don't know, that's about it.
Santa Cruz is interesting, I was...
- How do the points work?
- I'm, so there's a--
- (mumbles) Rotten Tomatoes?
- Hundred point, yeah,
it's kind of like that.
A hundred point scale,
hundred point scale.
Everything that's 90 and above
tends to get people's attention.
89 is like The Scarlet Letter.
Like, it's so fucking fucked up.
If you get an 89 point
score, nobody wants you.
Yet, like, it's completely subjective,
and a 90, everybody wants you.
- [Andre] And you get
90, you blow up, yup.
- [Gary] It's like being
second for the cover of Vogue.
- [Erin] It's like B+ student, man.
- Yeah, all right, that was wild.
- I really like it.
- I am blown away
that Parker would score that 93 points.
It's not his normal kind of jam.
- Not even close.
- Maybe he wasn't drunk.
- I built my career on
knowing Parker's palate.
- [Trout] It's Jeb Dunnuck.
- Oh, Jeb Dunnuck, who, by
the way, I'm a big fan of.
That makes it a little
bit more understanding,
but I still don't agree with Jeff.
- [Mary Kate] Is Parker a cool guy?
- I like Parker.
Have you interacted with him?
- Yeah, he seems cool.
- I like Parker,
I thought he was a legend.
- Well, I mean, the things is, is like,
why be mad at him because
everybody follows him?
- Because he's the gangster, and I,
I was a big fan.
- Yeah, everybody
followed him, I get it.
You know what, Erin, he was
the most powerful wine critic,
he was a lawyer from Maryland,
and I thought he was unbelievably
humble for his power.
And the only people that hated him,
is when they, when he
reviewed their wine poorly,
and I have a lot of admiration for him.
And what I earlier said, five seconds ago,
I built my career on him.
I mean that because, once
I understood what he liked,
I was able, you know how you said
you were in tune with your body?
I'm super in tune with a
lot of things, actually,
which is why I think I've done well,
and I was able to literally go backwards,
reverse engineer his palate,
and over the course of,
like, five to eight years,
got to a place where, whether
I agreed with him or not,
I had a good intuition on how
he would think about that wine
and that serviced me well
because I would make bets,
buy hundreds and hundreds
of cases of wine,
that would always fit this criteria.
I liked it, and I thought
he would score it well.
And I ended up being the
person that had all the wine
when, four months later, in the Advocate,
a 95 point score would come out.
- [Erin] Man, that's like an intuition
thing at both ends.
- A hundred percent.
- It's like, being like
I'm gonna go with this guy,
and I know what he's gonna like,
that's empathy.
- Okay, Andre and I
like number four.
You were a number two girl,
you were number one girl.
- Actually, I had said two and four.
- So let's unveil number three.
- [Andre] The one that we didn't like,
that no one picked?
- Number two.
- Oh, yeah, number two got beat up pretty,
I'm sorry, number three
got beat up pretty good.
Okay, Envy Wines Cabernet
Calistoga Estate 2014.
- [Trout] $55 retail.
- $55?
- [Trout] $48.99 at Wine Library.
- Okay, $48.99, fine,
good job Wine Library.
- What a steal.
- 91 Parker, wow, this time Parker Parker?
- [Trout] Parker Parker.
- We didn't agree.
We didst not agree on the show.
All right, one, two, four, okay.
So we're gonna unveil number one first.
Erin, this is your wine.
- [Erin] I think I'm ...
- This is your wine,
you liked it too, Andre.
- [Andre] Yeah, I did, I did.
- Erin, do you wanna just leave it
in the brown bag for you to take?
- This is brown bagged and foiled.
- Maybe
- [Andre] We'll get you a do-rag as well.
- Wow, Janasse Cotes du Rhone Blanc!
Erin, this is a pretty legit
producer, I'm a big fan.
- [Erin] I hope it's expensive.
- [Trout] 90 points Jeb Dunnuck.
- 90 points Jeb Dunnuck.
- $16 at Wine Library dot com.
- Fudge.
- Sixt, what are you.
- Well actually--
- Why did you go "fudge?"
No-no-no-no-no, you
shouldn't be disappointed
that you're under-$20-girl,
you should be pumped
that you found something--
- I know,
every time I'm under-$20-girl,
I just, like...
(laughter and applause)
Every time,
I'm such a cheap date!
- The word is out,
fellas, the word is out.
- I love it, Seth, good
news, 16 bucks, bro.
- I just don't like that bougie stuff.
It always rubs me
the wrong way.
- Trouty you are out,
Wine number two, this is your wine.
Mary Kate, you ready?
- [Mary Kate] Very excited.
- Let me take a peek at this.
- You know,
it makes sense on the Cotes
du Rhone Blanc, right.
- [Andre] Yeah, because it
wasn't really high in acid.
- [Erin] What type of wine is this?
- And this was a white
burgundy, we had it, right?
Yep, Génot-Boulanger, do
you know this producer?
This is a Chassagne-Montrachet.
- No, I don't know the producers.
- Trouty, what do you got?
This is a small producer,
Domaine Génot-Boulanger
Chassagne-Montrachet Premier Cru 2014,
single vineyard Les Vergernais.
- [Trouty] We've got 91 Wine
Spectator, $90 Wine Library.
- $90...
- Somewhere, lots of people are
shaking their head.
- This is a Cru selection,
this is Robert Bohr.
- $90, is it Robert Bohr?
- [Andre] Yeah, yeah.
- Big shout-out to Mr. Bohr,
who we both love.
- Whose that?
- 90 bucks, really awesome
dude, used to be the head of,
he used to be at Zachy's,
then he was the head of Cru,
which was a big time...
And now he's got a bunch of restaurants
here in New York City.
What's the up burst...
- And he started this company.
- Charlie Bird, you know
Charlie Bird, right?
The restaurant?
- Yeah, yes.
That's who it is.
- That's it man.
- 90 bucks.
- [Mary Kate] Please don't cut me.
- [Gary] You feel so good, right?
High class lady.
God, I wish this was visual.
All right, Mr. Mac, you
and I, I mean, we agreed,
which puts extra pressure on us,
because we're supposed to be.
- I'm so curious.
- [Andre] And we're like, just shit, oh!
- Talk about it.
Tell 'em what it is.
- Grange des Pères,
one of the greatest...
(laughter)
- [Gary] By the way, let's
just stop right there.
- Oh my god, your face.
- He's very proud.
- It's so cute,
it's like you just saw your child.
- You have to understand why we're proud.
This is a, this was double blind.
We knew nothing, and
you have to understand,
for us, there were bigger stakes here,
which is, we'd like to
be proud of what we like.
- [Erin] This is like Remember the Titans.
- Nah, dude, this is one
of the greatest wines,
it's one of the greatest wines of France,
Grange des Pères, it's 2012.
And I haven't had this wine in years.
- [Gary] It was great.
- [Erin] It's like seeing an old friend.
- Ah, Mr. Troutman?
- $105.
- [Trouty] Totally
unrated, it's a cult wine.
It just doesn't score it, yeah.
- What's the grape breakdown
on this, do you know?
Do you know, Trout,
can you look it up?
- I have no idea anymore.
- [Erin] What a curve ball.
- I'm gonna actually gonna pour myself--
- Can I have more, thank you so much.
- [Trouty] 40% Syrah, 40% Mourvedre.
- [Gary] 40% Syrah?
- [Trouty] 40% Mourvedre.
The 20% is a balance
of field grapes.
- Got it.
- Mourvedre, which is a great grape,
and 20% field grapes, pour that.
Andre, I'm pretty happy with myself here.
I expect to, like, have some bad episodes
of Brown Bags, but, I think
with drilled this one.
- [Erin] I almost cried.
- [Andre] It's all game.
- Was this the one that I
said if it was 20 bucks,
it'd be a good yeah.
(laughter)
Guys, it's not 20 bucks,
it's a hundred and five.
It didn't work out, but, good news.
A couple of you are ballers,
so instead of buying a dumb fucking watch
or Lamborghini, buy a case of this wine.
It will...
- [Erin] Take me out
for dinner, I'm cheap.
(laughter)
- [Gary] No, no, Erin, you're $16.
This is a hundred and five.
They can take you on ten dates,
eight dates, seven.
- No, I know, that's my wine,
I, okay, yeah (laughs)
- Seven dates with Erin, or this bottle.
Seth, you're still young in your career.
Great news, you can afford the supermodel.
Um, let's wrap it up.
Mr. Mac, what do you got to say?
Good first or, do you feel
the way I do, which is,
there's a good chance that
in your Wikipedia entry,
being a guest on episode
one of Brown Bags, may,
that we're onto something here?
- Yes, it's gonna change my life.
- [Gary] (laughs) Erin?
- Oh my god, I don't even know where I am.
(all laughing)
- You can't feel your face?
- [Gary] Mary Kate?
- I felt, I feel like I found
three new best friends today.
- [Gary] What, we weren't friends before?
- No, best friends.
- [Gary] Seth, Seth.
- Seth.
- [Gary] Seth, you found Seth.
- I found Seth.
Um, I love you guys, I love
wine, and I'm so excited
for this to be the only
episode of this show.
(all laughing)
- Mary Kate, we'll start with
you and go the other way.
I love culture hacking.
What's happening in culture right now
that has your attention?
Let's end with this.
- That's a great question.
- It's a great thing to end with.
It's our new thing, I just
made it up on the spot.
- [Erin] Wait, I have to think.
- I understand, good news, you're second.
- It's all in my ear.
It's, like, we've all been walking around
with earphones and Beats
and Pods and whatnot
for the past couple years, but now,
it's cerebral and it's smart in podcasts,
and like, it's ridiculously
dope with Jay-Z's new album.
It's just everything...
- Do you love the new album?
- I love, it's on repeat,
I love it so much.
And then it's Alexa...
- Him admitting that he was...
- [Mary Kate] Oh, Becky,
all of it, it's so good!
- Like, him admitting
that he was a bad guy,
weirdly makes him a great guy?
Explain this to me from
a female perspective.
- It's, yeah, it's, that's...
- [Gary] Is that where fame
just lets you do anything?
- Well, no, because that's--
- I have a funny feeling that
if Seth admitted that he cheated on Erin,
that she'd be, not like,
"He's a great guy."
- [Mary Kate] Well, how about
this week being like--
- Erin.
- If he cheated, I'd be like,
oh, thanks for the
telling me, saved my time.
- No, it's like the,
it's like that email doc.
It's like Donald Trump Junior being like,
"Here are the emails that
show that there's collusion."
Like, it's, no, it doesn't work.
- [Gary] So, in your ear is
what's most interesting to you.
- In my ear, it's all
happening, it's awesome.
- [Gary] You agree with
me that voice, sound...
- A thousand percent, I see
the three-year-old Charlie
asking Alexa to play "Imperial March."
- [Gary] Alexa, please
play "Imperial March."
- It's like the seventh time today.
By John C. Williams.
("Imperial March" by John C. Williams)
- Erin?
- Do we have the rights to this song?
- [Gary] Shh!
Mary Kate, you're finished.
- What do you mean in culture?
- What is happening in the
world that has your attention?
An artist, an event--
- Stand-up comedy.
- [Gary] What?
- [Gary] Stand, Alexa, stand-up,
all right, that's fine.
Alexa, please stop, (laughs) don't stand.
Alexa, please stop.
- Sit down.
Be humble.
- [Gary] All right, Erin.
- Comedy, dude, that's the
only thing, that's all I do.
- [Gary] You do stand-up comedy,
or you consume it?
- No, no, I just consume it.
- [Gary] Who are you interested in now?
- I've watched everything on Netflix
and I learned something about myself.
It's pretty depressing.
(laughs) I had to re-watch
The Rez last night.
(laughter)
And I've seen it already.
- Have you watched
Chappelle's stand-ups?
Parts one and two?
- Yeah, of course, yeah.
Yeah.
- Okay, fair, comedy.
- [Erin] No, I'm like,
deep, deep in comedy.
Like, I've been watching comedy
since I was a little kid.
Like, that's my wine.
- Who's your favorite
stand-up comedian of all time?
- Louis C.K., obviously,
but he lived in my apartment
before me, I get his mail.
And I didn't even know
that, that's the line.
- [Gary] Your actual apartment?
- Yes.
- [Gary] Amazing.
- Seth is so excited.
- [Gary] What is your favorite, all-time,
comedian, Mary Kate?
- It's funny because I just
watched it on a flight,
the documentary on Misery Loves Comedy?
Did you guys see that?
- Of course, but then?
- Oh shit, I'm naked.
- I like how you're buying time.
Who's your favorite all-time comedian?
Stand-up, stand-up.
- [Mary Kate] See, that's a problem.
- All right, I'll go,
Richard Pryor for me.
Mr. Mac?
- [Andre] Rock.
- Chris Rock, and for you?
- I don't wanna sound like the girl
who picked the second
most expensive wine here,
but I feel like Seinfeld did something
to make comedy, like, very accessible.
But, I don't love his stand-up.
Jerry, if you're listening,
I'm so sorry.
- Interesting,
I thought he was great.
I saw recently at, where was he?
Yeah, at Broadside, where was he?
Yeah.
- I go to comedy stuff
by myself all the time.
It's like my hobby.
- [Mary Kate] Best friend, should we go
to the comedy show now?
- Now you can go with Seth.
Seth, where are you taking Erin?
Which comedy club are
you and Erin going to
on your first date?
- Which is your fave?
(laughter)
- [Gary] Andre, favorite stand-up comic.
Oh, I'm sorry, excuse
me, culture, culture.
- Culture, I mean, lots
of different things
have piqued my interest.
Obviously from a wine standpoint,
I really feel like athletes,
and people who look like
me, that whole genre,
black folks don't really drink wine.
Let's just put it out there, you know.
It's not a...
- [Gary] Yeah, obviously,
this is audio, Andre is black.
- You know what I mean,
so there's not a, like,
I'm excited to see that, you know,
LeBron James just did this whole video
of them in the barbershop,
Steve Stoute shows up
with nine year Latour
- Stoute!
- That's hardcore wine.
Stoute loves wine, Jay-Z loves
wine, you know this before.
- Totally, yeah.
- You think that's cool, right?
- I think it's cool
because what happens is,
we live in a world where--
- [Gary] Are you holding
that Weezy texts you
and says, like--
- I already had that meeting.
- [Gary] You did.
- Yeah.
- Well, let's wait a minute.
Let's extend this.
- We already had that meeting, but they,
it's so much--
- Was Birdman there?
- No, there were a
whole bunch of attorneys
from Capitol Records that were there.
- Oh, from a business standpoint,
you were thinking about doing a JV with...
- [Andre] We were doing
something with them,
but the same reason why you left
is the same reason why they're
like, fuck, dude, like,
it's so much, I mean it's
easier to ship toxic waste
in this country than it is
to shape a case of wine.
- Literally, guys, you
can buy a grenade online
easier than you can buy wine.
- Why?
- And they were like,
fuck it, you know what?
We're in the books.
- Prohibition, prohibition, uh-huh.
- [Andre] So they went with
a totally different way.
- But wait a minute, take a step back.
Wayne is like the best.
- I love him.
- Were you like, losing your
mind that you were there?
- No, you know, I've met people before.
- Yeah, but, like, you
know how it is, though.
Like, like, of course you've
met cool people before,
famous people.
- And now you've met Erin.
- But like yeah, I mean...
- [Andre] I know, I had no idea.
- And now?
- [Andre] We were just talking.
- The comedy cellar, don't
(laughter)
- Oh my God.
- You flawed when she said vom, right.
- I think culturally,
you know what I mean,
like let's just talk about it.
- Wine is cooler than it's ever been.
- Black folks didn't drink tequila.
T-Pain, and Usher started
talking about Patrone,
and the next thing you
know, they are backward,
and in New York.
You know, something that's
considered kind of a--
- Let's be very clear.
Hip-Hop.
- Yeah.
- Is the foundation of culture.
- [Andre] Okay.
- Like that is very clear in 2017.
- [Erin] Do we all watch The Defiant Ones?
- [Andre] Yep, it is amazing.
- I'm only listening
to Snoop Dog right now.
- [Gary] You love Snoop?
- Yeah, I love Snoop.
I'm listening to music pre 2000,
for everything I pitied.
- Post 2004, everything sucks.
- Everything sucked after that.
- [Gary] You hate Drake in the weekend.
- I don't know, I'm not a hater.
- [Gary] Well, you just said they suck.
- No, no, but there's something about...
It's just like smell, it's
the strongest connection
to your memories.
- [Gary] 2004, is the
strongest connection to you.
- There's just something
about listening to music
that's from the time you love.
- Nate,
what's your favorite music?
- My favorite music--
- Whose your favorite, John Mayer,
who I was with last night,
and didn't invite you.
- He did show up?
- [Gary] Yeah, and you are super
upset with me.
- Totally super sad.
- [Erin] You love John Mayer?
- [Gary] John's fuckin' wild.
- [Mary Kate] Nate is
your body on an Island?
- [Gary] Nate take the shirt off.
Guys watch this, Nate
please take the shirt off.
- Nate, take the shirt--
- He made me do this
at an L.A holiday.
(all laughing)
- [Gary] Can you do it again Nate?
- [Mary Kate] This is like
a Podcast, no one could see.
- It's devastating.
- [Andre] And then the
other thing is, is that,
I'm big on voice, I've
been on voice dictation
for the last four years.
I answer all my emails that way.
I'm writing my
new book that way.
- Is that right?
- My kids know how to do it,
they can't even spell shit,
but they know the double tap,
f-ing key on the computer,
and then they say what they want.
- Andre, do you still
have that Beaune Thugs,
Beaune T-shirt thing.
- Yeah.
- Can you send me one?
I need to rock that.
- Yeah sure.
- What is it again?
What does it say?
- [Andre] Just says
Beaune Thugs and Burgundy.
- Right, because guys, for
everybody whose watching,
Beaune, is like this region in France,
and so that's the way he spells it.
I love Bone Thugs, and so when I saw that,
like I loved that stuff.
- I love Bone Thugs.
- And so, like culturally,
like I'm excited for a lot
of like what technology
has like put us.
You know, I showed up to New York,
and like nobody in the wine business
had a Blackberry.
- Nope.
- Everybody made fun
of me in the restaurant
because I always had
headphones on, everyone.
Like my parting gift, when in left in '07,
was Bose headphones, right.
Cause everybody just
thought that was funny.
And then a year or two later,
everybody is walking
around, and everybody has
headphones on.
- Right, do you make
fun of them now?
Like do you see them,
and be like--
- No, no, no,
we just kinda let it be known.
- That you established it
- Well, that's interesting
cause you're auditory
that's why you speak.
That's what your veered towards.
- [Andre] Yeah, and it's
just so much easier,
my whole thing is like,
I wanna write this book
100% voice dictation.
- That's right.
- What does it talk about?
- It's just a part memoir, part wine book.
Partly my life, and part about--
- By the way, Andre's wife,
wrote an incredible book.
- [Erin] I wanna know who she is,
I didn't wanna bother you about it.
- She is so fuckin' bad ass.
- [Andre] She is the real shit.
- You see how much you like him.
- [Erin] I heard about his kids.
- Yeah, but you how much you
like him right now, right.
He's literally a piece of
shit compared to Pheobes.
- Really?
- He sucks.
- Absolutely yeah.
- Like huge mistake having him here.
(all laughing)
This should have been Pheobe's spot.
- [Erin] What's Pheobe's thing man?
What's her name?
I wanna look her up.
- First of all,
The thing that I most love about myself,
is that I don't waver.
(Andre laughing)
I'm being serious, I do not waver
- I appreciate that.
- Pheobe does not waver.
Like when I think of the
people I've met in my life,
in my life!
And this was a period in
time from 2000, '6, '7, '8
when we would hang out a bunch.
Like Pheobe does not waver, I
respect the shit out of that.
- Yeah, she is who she is.
- [Mary Kate] That's a good quality.
- It's a great quality.
- She is like no,
I don't like that
- You know who wavers a lot?
Trouty.
(laughs) I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
- [Erin] Whose Trouty?
- Trouty is that guy right there,
that you haven't noticed yet.
(all laughing)
You know what, that's a
perfect way to end this show.
Guys thank you so much,
Andre, Erin, Mary Kate,
thank you for being
the pioneers.
- Bye guys.
- I love you guys.
- Thank you.
- Love.
- We'll link you up, make sure everybody
in the Vineyard Nation, knows who you are.
Guys, thank you for
listening, to Brown Bags one.
We'll decide if there's
a two, this might be it.
Goodnight.
Leave a comment, with your
favorite part, of the episode.
Who said the funniest thing?
What was the most fun?
Leave your three cents.
See you.
(upbeat music)